I AM CALLING.
THIS HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO ORDER AS
A SUB COMMITTEE ONLY RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WE IT APPEARS WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL WHEN THERE IS A QUORUM --
WE HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS ON FILE
TODAY TO OUR ON CONSENT THE
MEASURE ON AS THE MEASURES ON
CONSENT ARE AB FIFTY TWO WITH
THE MEASUREMENTS IN A C. R..
EIGHT I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND THE
AUTHORS THAT THERE SHOULD BE
ONLY TWO MAIN WITNESSES --
TWO MINUTES EACH TO INTO TWO IN
THIS IS TWO MINUTES EACH ONLY.
ALL OTHER SUPPORT OPPOSITION MAY
LINE UP AT THE MICROPHONE A
STATE THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL.
ONLY.
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WHEN WE
DO ADD ON VOTES AT THE END OF
THE HEARING WILL ASK MEMBERS TO
STAY SEATED.
WELL THE SECRETARY AGAIN CALLS
ARE ALL THAT'S AT THE END WHEN
WE'RE DOING ADD ON'S --
IN WILL HOLD OFF ON OUR OUR OUR
OUR POLICY ADOPTIONS --
WITH THAT AND WE DON'T WE GO
AHEAD -- MR
MEDINA.
WILL BE OUR FIRST AUTHOR.
MR MEDIAN AS TWO BILLS --
AB EIGHT THIRTY ONE IN AB.
FOR TWENTY EIGHT AND I DON'T
HAVE A FILE NUMBER [inaudible]
OKAY.
FIRST WAS FILE ITEM NINE FILE
ITEM NINE WHICH IS AB. THREE
THREE ONE THREE THREE ONE THREE
THREE ONE AB THREE THROUGH ONE
FILE ITEM NINE IS IS.
IS THE FIRST BILL UP.
YOU MAY PERCEIVE AN READY MISTER
MEDINA THANK YOU.
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TODAY IT IS MY HONOR. TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE THIRTY ONE ETHNIC STUDIES
BILL.
AND WITH ME THIS MORNING IS
DOCTOR ALBERT COME IDEAL FROM
STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
AND WE ARE ALSO EXPECTING OUR
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION --
TONY THURMOND [inaudible]
ETHNIC STUDIES.
IN THE CURRICULUM THAT IT
REPRESENTS AND THE CURRICULUM
THAT IT IT WILL INCLUDE.
IS SOMETHING THAT IS MUCH NEEDED
IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
AS A ETHNIC STUDIES CHICANO
STUDIES TEACHER AT POLY HIGH
SCHOOL.
I SAW FIRST HAND.
THE POWER OF THE CURRICULUM THAT
INCLUDES STUDENTS BACKGROUND
STUDENTS HISTORY AND STUDENTS
CULTURE.
WHEN WE LOOK AT WAYS OF
IMPROVING PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION?
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE AT EDUCATION
ACHIEVEMENT GAP?
AND WE LOOK FOR WAYS TO REMEDY
THAT ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
WE LOOK AT THINGS LIKE
DISCIPLINEAND RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE.
THE THOSE ARE ONE WAY OF GOING
ABOUT TRYING.
TO A THE CULTURE OF EDUCATION.
BUT ANOTHER WAY OF CHANGING THE
CULTURE OF EDUCATION IS LOOKING
AT WHAT IS TAUGHT.
WHAT IS TAUGHT WHAT IS INCLUDED?
AND WHAT IS NOT INCLUDED.
WHEN I WENT THROUGH --
PUBLIC -- MY
EDUCATION TRAINING PROGRAM AT UC
RIVERSIDE.
I LEARNED ABOUT THE HIDDEN
CURRICULUM.
AND THAT THAT IS WHAT IS IMPLIED
OR WOULD STUDENTS LEARN.
A NOT WHAT IS IN THE TEXTBOOK
BUT WHAT THE WAY THEY ARE
PRESENTED WITH MATERIAL A WHAT
IS VALUED AND WHAT IS NOT VALUED.
AND TOO LONG FOR TOO LONG.
IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS --
WHEN WE DO NOT INCLUDE STUDENTS
CULTURE STUDENTS HISTORY?
STUDENTS BACKGROUND WHERE THEY
COME FROM THE STORIES OF THEIR
FAMILIES.
WE IMPLICITLY SEND A MESSAGE
THAT THAT CULTURE THAT HISTORY
IS NOT A VALUE.
BECAUSE IT IS NOT IN THE
CURRICULUM IT IS NOT TAUGHT.
WHEN I WAS TEACHING ETHNIC
STUDIES CHICANO STUDIES AT POLY
HIGH SCHOOL I I HAD A STUDENT IN
MY CLASS WHO WENT TO OUR HISTORY
TEACHER?
SHE WENT OUR HISTORY TEACHER AND
SHE ASKED HER HISTORY TEACHER
ABOUT THE NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT
WALK OUT.
IN EAST LA OF THE STUDENTS.
AND APPARENTLY THAT US HISTORY
TEACHER WAS NOT AWARE OF IT.
SO IT WAS ALMOST LIKE THE US
HISTORY TEACHER I TOLD HER THAT
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
WE NEED TO CHANGE T
TO CHANGE THAT KIND OF EDUCATION.
I LEARNED IN MY ETHNIC STUDIES
CLASS THAT --
WE DRAW CIRCLES THAT WE DRAW
CIRCLES TO INCLUDE OR TO EXCLUDE
PEOPLE.
THAT WE CAN DRAW THE CIRCLE
BRINGING PEOPLE IN.
OR WE CAN DRAW THE CIRCLE TO
KEEP PEOPLE WE TEACH DOES THAT.
IF WE DRAW THE CIRCLE TO INCLUDE
PEOPLE WE WILL DRAW THE CIRCLE
TO INCLUDE THIS CURRICULA.
CURRICULUM IS BEING DEVELOPED
NOW.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
AND THAT I AND MANY.
OF MY COLLEAGUES ONE IS C. AS A
COLLEGE GRADUATION REQUIREMENT
MOVING FORWARD.
DISCIPLINE.
SINCE.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BECAME A
DISCIPLINE IN NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE WHEN THE STUDENTS AND
FACULTY MEMBERS THE SAN
FRANCISCO STATE WALKED OUT AND
DEMANDED.
THAT THAT KIND OF CURRICULA
BEING COLLUDED --
AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE --
AND IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I WAS LOOKING BEHIND ME I
THOUGHT MAYBE --
OUR SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IT COME BUT HE'S NOT
HERE YET.
WHEN HE COMES IN ALL OF THAT
THANK YOU FOR IT?
THANK YOU.
SO FOR THE LAST SO THAT THE
CURRICULUM.
IT HAS EXISTED.
IT IS BEEN TAUGHT.
BUT WE'VE WAITED A LONG TIME FOR
THAT CORRECT THEM TO BE INCLUDED
IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA PRIDES ITSELF OF
BEING A LEADER.
BEING A LEADER IN THIS COUNTRY.
BUT OTHER STATES ARE AHEAD OF US
IN CALLING FOR ETHNIC STUDIES
STATES LIKE VERMONT [inaudible]
CONNECTICUT WASHINGTON.
INDIANA HAVE ALL CALLED FOR
ETHNIC STUDIES.
STATE IN THE NATION.
OUR STUDENTS DESERVE TO LEARN
ABOUT THEIR PAST THEIR CULTURE
THEIR HISTORY.
ETHNIC STUDY WILL NOT SOLVE ALL
OUR PROBLEMS.
BUT I THINK ETHNIC STUDIES IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO
THAT THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
AT NOR OF HIGH SCHOOL IN OH HI.
PORT NEWPORT HIGH SCHOOL OR HIGH
SCHOOL IN NEWPORT WERE STUDENTS
CREATED SWASTIKAS OUT OF PAPER
CUPS.
SO THAT THINGS LIKE THAT WON'T
HAPPEN AS OFTEN.
SO I AM VERY PLEASED TO HAVE
WITH ME --
PROFESSOR ALBERT COME IDEA A
PROFESSOR AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY
IS THE AUTHOR OF CHICANOS IN A
CHANGING SOCIETY PAST PRESIDENT.
OF THE AMERICAN HISTORICAL
ASSOCIATION.
AND YOUR TO PRESENT IN SUPPORT
OF ETHNIC STUDIES DOCTOR
COMMITTEE.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY JOIN YOU
FOR A FEW MINUTES THAT THIS
MORNING IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE THIRTY ONE I'VE HAD THE
GREAT PLEASURE AND PRIVILEGE
OVER THE LAST SEVEN YEARS --
OF PARTICIPATING STANFORD
UNIVERSITY DEPARTMENT HISTORY
WITH TO CHARTER HIGH SCHOOLS IN
THE BAY AREA OF SAN FRANCISCO
BERRIES PAULA ALL TO ACADEMY
HIGH END OF RELATIVELY NEW
CHARTER SCHOOL.
IN SAN JOSE LUIS FATHERS
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY OF DEVELOPING
AND INSTITUTING AN ETHNIC
STUDIES CURRICULUM IN THIS CASE
MEXICAN AMERICAN HISTORY.
AND I CAN TELL YOU FIRSTHAND
FROM THAT UNIQUE EXPERIENCE.
THE TRANSFORMATIVE IMPACT THAT
IT'S HAD ON STUDENTS THAT THESE
TWO HIGH SCHOOLS --
IT IS CLEAR TO ME AND SO MANY OF
THE TEACHERS INVOLVED IN THE THE
OPERATIONAL SESSION
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF THIS
CURRICULUM.
THAT IT HIS CENTER TRAJECTORY OF
FOR THESE STUDENTS TO EXCEL.
IN THEIR HIGH SCHOOLS UP AND
TOWARDS COLLEGE READINESS.
NOW I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT THE
ETHNIC STUDIES RELATED CURRICULA
LOAN IS IS A REASON FOR A
TRAJECTORY TOWARDS HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR PARTICULARLY AT
YOUTH.
RISK BUT IT'S PLAYED SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN BRINGING A
CRITICAL SENSIBILITY.
BY AN APPRECIATION FOR SO RICK
IN THE STUDENTS HAD NEVER
ENCOUNTERED SO WHAT THESE TWO
HIGH SCHOOLS --
SPECIALLY LOUISE WELL THIS
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY NINTH GRADERS
ARE REQUIRED TO TAKE THIS COURSE
WHICH WE DEVELOPED TOGETHER AND
IMPLEMENTED BY THE HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHERS.
AND IN IN THAT SCHOOL THE END
AND PUTTING IN A LARGER CONTEXT
ABOUT SCHOOL READINESS AND THE
THE IMPACT IT HAS ON ENERGIZING
THEIR EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
THESE HIGH SCHOOLS.
ABOUT 27% OF LATINO STUDENTS
ENTER FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES IN CALIFORNIA 75% OF
THE FIRST GRADUATING CLASS LAST
JUNE FROM LOUISE FALL THERE'S
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY.
HAVE NOW ENTERED FOUR YEAR --
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES AND THERE
ARE MANY TESTIMONIES THAT
THEY'VE GIVEN BACK TO US AND IN
THEIR STATEMENTS OF ADMISSION TO
COLLEGE COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES OF
THE VALUE THE IMPACT OF HAVING
THAT EXPOSURE TO THAT CURRICULUM.
EARLY ON THAT ESTABLISH A BASIS
FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT WITH
EDUCATION ESPECIALLY SOCIAL
STUDIES.
SO IT'S BEEN A HEART WARMING AND
AND IN IN ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT
EXPERIENCE FOR ME TO SEE THE WAY
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS CAN TAKE
THIS CURRICULUM AND INCORPORATED
INTO THEIR TRAJECTORIES FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
I THE SUPER TEN HASN'T SHOWN UP
BUT IF HE DOES SHOW UP.
WE WILL --
WE WILL CERTAINLY BRING THEM
FORWARD MISTER MEDINA PORT.
DID YOU WANNA YEAH I I I JUST.
I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE GOING TO TAKE
OKAY -- THE
WAY.
GOOD GOOD OKAY.
SO WHEN I THANK THE CHAIR FOR
AND THE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK AND AND FOR THE RECORD --
STATE THAT I ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THE THAT WE WORKED ON
TOGETHER.
AND I JUST WANTED --
TO READ WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS
ARE SO THAT WE'RE ALL CLEAR.
FIRST AMENDMENT IS TO MOVE THE
AMPLE.
IMPLEMENTATION DATE FORWARD TO
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
SCHOOL YEAR.
SECOND ONE IS THAT STUDENTS
SHALL COMPLETE A ONE SEMESTER
COURSE IN THAT ETHNIC STUDIES
BASED ON THE MODEL CURRICULUM.
THE PUPILS MAY FULFILL THIS
REQUIREMENT THROUGH COMPLETION
OF EITHER OF THE FOLLOWING TYPES
OF COURSES.
SUBJECT TO THE COURSE OFFERINGS
OF THE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY.
OR CHARTER SCHOOL.
FIRST AN ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE
SECOND AND ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE
TAUGHT AS A COURSE IN ANOTHER
SUBJECT.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
SUBJECTS IN WHICH COURSES ARE
REQUIRED FOR GRADUATION FROM
HIGH SCHOOL BY THE STATE OR OF
APPLICABLE BY THE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY.
OR CHARTER SCHOOL.
OF COURSE WHICH DOES NOT USE
ETHNIC STUDIES CONTACT.
CONTENT AS THE PRIMARY CONTENT
THROUGH WHICH THE SUBJECT IS
TAUGHT DOES NOT SATISFY THIS
REQUIREMENT. FOR COURSES TAUGHT
THROUGH ANOTHER SUBJECT PUPILS
COMPLETING THE COURSE SHALL ALSO
OCCUR CREDIT FOR THE COURSE WORK
IN THE SUBJECT.
WHICH THE COURSES OFFERED
INCLUDING OF APPLICABLE CREDIT
TOWARDS STATE AND ANY OTHER
LOCAL REQUIREMENT FOR GRADUATION
FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
THIRD PERMITTED THE REQUIRE
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE BE OFFERED
IN ANY DISCIPLINE NOT ONLY
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS AND SOCIAL
STUDIES.
PROVIDED THAT IS BASED ON THE
ETHNIC STUDIES MODEL CURRICULA.
SINCE THE MODEL CURRICULUM WILL
BE DESIGNED TO ENGAGE A RANGE OF
DISCIPLINES BEYOND TRADITIONAL
HISTORY AND SOCIAL SCIENCES.
INCLUDING VISUAL AND PERFORMING
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS ECONOMIC
AND GENDER AND SEXUALITY STUDIES.
FOR CLARIFIED THAT THIS AND THE
OTHER GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS
APPLY TO CHARTER SCHOOL.
THOSE ARE THE AMENDMENTS AND
VERY HAPPILY TO TAKE THOSE AMEND.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR PASSION
ON THIS ISSUE AND NOW WHAT WE GO
TO THE PUBLIC NOW ALL OTHERS IN
SUPPORT MAY COME FOR STATE THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL.
ONLY PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS ACTUALLY
WALKER WITH NASA MEN ON BEHALF
OF THE MODERATE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE DO HAVE SUPPORT
IF AMENDED POSITION WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THE
AUTHORS TAKEN AND WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THIS OFFICE THANK
YOU.
I TELL ALLEN THE COLLEGE OF
EDUCATION SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CHRIS ADAMS WITH THE PEOPLE'S
ALLIANCE --
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE BILL HOPE
IT GETS PASS.
ISABEL GARCIA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE TAKING A FORMAL POSITION
ON THE BILL AT THE END OF THE
MONTH.
BUT WE URGE YOUR PASSAGE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO ETHNIC BASED ARE THAT
STANDARDS BASED ETHNIC ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSES THANK YOU.
GIVE OUR CO WITH THE SOUTHEAST
ASIA RESOURCE ACTION CENTER --
WE SAW THAT A LOT OF THE OUR
STUDENTS WERE EXPERIENCING
CULTURAL INVISIBILITY LARGELY
BECAUSE THEIR HISTORIES ARE NOT
BEING TAUGHT IN SCHOOL
ESPECIALLY SOUTHEAST ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER STUDENTS.
SO WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
PUSH OFFICE ROBBIE WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION WE STAND
STRONG SUPPORT SUPPORT FOR IT
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
I ANY COMMENTS FROM THE COULD
YOU ALSO SHARE WITH YOU AYE MR
ANY THANK YOU FOR YOUR PASSION.
YOUR EXPERIENCE FIRST RIGHT AND
YOUR PASSION ON THIS ISSUE --
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
AWHILE SO I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
YOU TODAY --
SUNDAY IS ST PATRICK'S DAY SO I
HOPE YOU'LL REMEMBER THE CENTURY
COS ON SUNDAY RIGHT.
RIGHT FORGET RIGHT ON SO OF YOU
KNOW MAKE MAINLY YOU KNOW THE
STUDENTS ARE MAINLY LATINO THERE
SO I THINK THE MORE THEY CAN
LEARN ABOUT THEMSELVES.
AND THE OTHER STUDENTS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THEMSELVES IS
ONLY A GOOD THING --
TO GIVE THEM YOU KNOW SOME PRIDE
FOR SURE --
BUT ALSO BELIEVE NO WE KNOW
WHERE THEY FIT IN THE WORLD SO
THANK YOU FOR FOR FOR FOR TODAY
BOTH OF YOU BUT THE WITH THAT I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER.
A DOCUMENT YES I SORRY I WAS
LATE TIED UP IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE BUT I AM PROUD TO BE
ONE OF THE CO AUTHORS ON THIS
BILL WITH MOST MEDINA.
WHO HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF TIME WORKING ON IT --
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW I SPENT
FORTY YEARS TEACHING ETHNIC
STUDIES AT SENEGAL STATE
UNIVERSITY IS ONE OF THE
FOUNDERS OF THE DEPARTMENT.
AND ONE OF THINGS THAT ALWAYS
STRUCK ME WAS THAT --
WHEN STUDENTS CAME INTO THE
DEPARTMENT FOR WHATEVER REASON
THROUGH WHATEVER MEANS --
THEY KNEW NOTHING ABOUT NOT ONLY
THEIR OWN HISTORY BOOK ABOUT THE
HISTORY THE PEOPLE WHO SAT IN
THE ROOM WITH THEM WE WENT TO
SCHOOL WITH THEM.
AND SO I ALWAYS THEY ALWAYS FELT
SOMEHOW ANOTHER THEY HAD BEEN
BETRAYED BY LAW SO YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY GOT TO THE UNIVERSITY AND
IT TOOK AN ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE
AND THEY DISCOVER THEY LACK SO
MUCH INFORMATION.
AND THESE WERE CONSIDERED OUR
BEST AND BRIGHTEST STUDENTS JUST
AS EARLIER WHY DID WE KNOW THIS
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT.
AND AND IT WAS REALLY CLEAR THAT
WE IF THAT WOULD REALLY GOING TO
DEAL WITH EDUCATION EVEN AT THE
UPPER LEVEL WITH BEGIN IT EARLY
SO THE YOUNG PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
IT.
AS WELL AS THE FACT THAT I DID
TEACH AN EPIC STUDIES COURSE OF
IN ON I AFER SCHOOL AT ONE OF
THE HIGH SCHOOLS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS -- AND
WAS INTERESTING HOW MANY
STUDENTS CAME WITHOUT CREDIT
AFTER SCHOOL FOR A BLACK HISTORY
COURSE.
WHO WANTED TO KNOW THE MATERIAL
WHOSE BEHAVIOR CHANGED IMMENSELY
AS A RESULT OF OF KNOWING THE
MATERIAL IN TERMS OF THEIR
PERFORMANCE IN THEIR OTHER
CLASSES?
BUT IT WAS ALWAYS AMAZING TO ME
THAT THESE YOUNG PEOPLE SHOWED
UP.
AFTER SCHOOL THEY HAD A HALF DAY
IN THE TO GO HOME THEY SHOWED UP
REGULARLY FOR THIS PARTICULAR
COURSE TO LEARN ABOUT BLACK
HISTORY.
AND SO AND IT WAS NOT ONLY
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS THAT
WILL ALSO ASIAN AND LATINO
STUDENTS WHO CAME TO THAT COURSE
AS WELL SO I THINK THE IDEA OF
STUDENTS WANTING TO KNOW WHO
THEY ARE YOU KNOW HAVING SPENT
ALL MY YEARS IN UNIVERSITY.
AND NOT STUDYING ETHNIC STUDIES
AT ALL UNTIL I BECAME A GROUP
PHD STUDENT --
THAT YOU FEEL THAT THERE'S A
SENSE OF LOSS YOU KNOW THAT YOU
COULD HAVE MAYBE DO WHO KNOWS
WHAT YOUR LIFE WOULD HAVE BEEN
LIKE.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT YOURSELF
BUT EQUALLY IMPORTANT EVEN
THOUGH AS MUCH AS I KNOW ABOUT
AFRICAN AMERICAN HISTORY I STILL
FEEL AN ADEQUATE IN TERMS OF
KNOWING MORE ABOUT LATINO
HISTORY.
AND I'M CONSTANTLY READING BOOKS
AND TRYING TO IF IT MORE KLAY
TEACHING ART BUT EVERYBODY
THAT'S A HAS BEEN A PART IN
AMERICAN HISTORY IT MAKES AND
STRONGER IT MAKES MORE
RESPECTFUL OF EACH OTHER.
AND IT JUST ENHANCES OUR LIFE
SIGNS I'M PLEASE WITH THIS IT'S
BEEN FIFTY YEARS SINCE AN ETHNIC
STUDIES WAS FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE BLACK STUDIES THEY
BEGIN THE MOVEMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IS TAKEN FIFTY YEARS FOR US
TO HOPEFULLY GET TO THIS POINT
WHERE WE REALLY GOING TO TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY IN TERMS OF PART OF
THE RIGHT THE CURRICULA TEACHING
K..
TWELVE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISSED MEDINA FOR YOUR
PERSISTENCE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER IN FACT
MY OLDEST BROTHER WENT ALONG TO
WE WENT TO SAN DIEGO STATE AND
TOOK AN IRISH HISTORY COURSE
THERE.
ON OVER THE ETHNIC STUDIES I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT WAS.
BUT AFTER THAT I KNOW MY FAMILY
BECAME MORE AND TURN INTO
WHETHER WITH OUR HISTORY FOR
SURE IN LONG BEACH UNIFIED DOES
A GREAT JOB.
AND YOU KNOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THIS GOING ON ACROSS THE STATE
THEY DO THEY ARE ACTUALLY OFFER
THESE JUST CONCURRENT ENROLLMENT.
SO YOU CAN GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL WAS SIX UNITS IN ETHNIC
STUDIES.
AND I THINK THEY ACTUALLY GO ON
THE WEEKENDS IT'S NOT DURING THE
SCHOOL DAY IT'S ACTUALLY ON THE
LONG BEACH STATE CAMPUS WHICH I
DO SEE AS A POSITIVE GETTING
KIDS UNDER THE UNIVERSITY CAMPUS.
SO THIS IS HAPPENING ACROSS OUR
STATE NOW ALBEIT NOT EVERYWHERE
AND THAT THAT'S YOUR GOAL TODAY.
IF I MAY CLOSE THE QUESTION UP.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND IT IS SO TIMELY IN
FACT OVERDUE I'M REALLY PROUD TO
REPRESENT A DISTRICT WHERE THERE
ARE DOZENS OF NATIVE CULTURES
AND VERY LIMITED OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CHILDREN.
TO LEARN THEIR OWN NATIVE
HISTORIES AND FOR ALL STUDENTS
TO LEARN THEIR PLACE IN OUR NEW
MORE GLOBAL CLIMATE SO I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'VE
AUTHORED THIS THAT YOU'VE
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT ALL.
OF THE IMMENSELY TALENTED SOCIAL
STUDIES TEACHERS ACROSS THE
STATE COME UP WITH TO IMPLEMENT
THIS PLAN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IF I MAY CLOSE MR.
YEAH I YOU KNOW LET LET US
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE'VE GOT
EVERYBODY HERE AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE YOU CLOSE.
DO SO I I DO WANT TO CALL THE
FULL COMMITTEE TO ORDER BECAUSE
I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM
PLEASE THIS CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL HERE.
KILEY.
KILEY HERE KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HERE SMITH.
SMITH HERE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER HERE.
WE DO HAVE A ONE THE COURT HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED WITHOUT I'M
SORRY CLOSE MISTER YEAH.
BUT THANK YOU TO ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR A OTHER SUPPORT.
THIS MORNING.
BEFORE I CAME TO THE CAPITOL I
OPENED UP.
OF JOAN DIDION SLOUCHING TO
BETHLEHEM AND SHE WRITES ABOUT
SUTTER'S MILL.
JUST A FEW MILES FROM HERE.
AND SHE WRITES ABOUT HOW SUTTER
MILL AND THE FOUNDING OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THAT EVENT WAS SEEN AS THE
FOUNDING OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IF THAT IS THE POINT OF VIEW
OF HISTORY IT IT IT ELIMINATES
OR SO MUCH.
THAT ALREADY EXISTED BEFORE --
THE THE PIONEERS CAME TO
CALIFORNIA THE NATIVE AMERICAN
HISTORY THAT MISS SMITH REFERRED
TO THE SPANISH HISTORY.
THE MEXICAN HISTORY OF THE STATE-OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO TOO OFTEN I THINK BUT THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY HAS BEEN
TAUGHT.
AS A MOVEMENT FROM.
FROM EAST TO WEST.
THE THE HISTORY THE RICHEST
HISTORY OF WHAT CAME BEFORE THAT
HAS BEEN LEFT OUT.
OF WHEN WE THINK OF THE FORTY
NINERS WE THINK OF ONLY ONE
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT THAT LEAVES
OUT THE THE ASIAN AMERICANS THAT
ALSO WE'RE HERE.
SO I'M VERY HAPPY --
THAT WE'RE MOVING THIS BILL FOR
AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ARE WITH THAT --
WE NEED A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY MISTER
MCCARTY SECOND MY DOCTOR WEBER --
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY EYES SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I FORTY ONE THE BILLS UP.
THANK YOU GOOD WORK MISTER
MEDINA THANK YOU.
SHE WE THREE IT UP OF THE ROLE
GUESTS AND ONE MORE.
TIME.
THANK YOU WHAT WHAT WE MOVED TO
ADOPT.
THE COMMITTEE POLICY AND
CURRICULUM MEASURES FOR THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
SESSION THE POLICY'S BEEN
DISTRIBUTED TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OFFICES.
IN ADVANCE ANY DISCUSSION.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION.
IS DO I HAVE A MOTION ON THE
POLICY -- SO
WITH THAT I THINK I FOUND THE
PROBLEM --
CURRICULUM IF YOU [inaudible]
THREE YEAH KURT.
PROCESS SO BASICALLY THE GOAL
STICK TO ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS.
AND WHICH IS ONE THE I. SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
I GUESS THEY WERE SAID THEY WERE
DISTURBED AS YOU CAN GET IT TOO
BUT THEY WERE DISTRIBUTED.
JUST KEEP KEEP CALL THE ROLL
SCHOOL TO PROTOCOL YES SIR WHERE
SHE HAD ONLY.
THE CHANNEL LATER YES JONES I
MADE IT ILL DID YOU DID YOU GET
[inaudible]
CURRICULA [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THAT'S PASSED [inaudible]
WEBER I OKAY SO THE COMMITTEE
POLICY ON CURRICULUM --
HAS BEEN ADOPTED.
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA GO TO BACK
TO MISTER MEDINA --
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE FILE
NUMBER [inaudible]
TWELVE AB. FOUR TWENTY EIGHT YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY FOUR
WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED FUNDING
FOR THE EQUALIZATION OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
FUNDING RATES FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION PRESCHOOL SERVICES AND
FOR HIGH COST PLACEMENTS.
OUR STUDENTS WITH EXCEPTIONAL
NEEDS DESERVE HIGH QUALITY OF
EDUCATION WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO
REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
BUT OUR CURRENTS BUDGET SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING SYSTEM.
PRESENTS BARRIERS WHERE THEY
SHOULD BE OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
DECADES CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING RATES HAVE
VARIED CONSIDERABLY.
WITHOUT ANY RATIONALE.
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN LIVING WITH
THESE INEQUITIES FOR NEARLY FOUR
DECADES.
AND ADDRESSING THEM IS SIMPLE
MATTER OF FAIRNESS.
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
PRESCHOOL ALSO PRESENTS A
BARRIER WHERE THERE SHOULD BE
OPPORTUNITY.
AT A CRITICAL TIME IN CHILDREN'S
LIVES CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A FREE AND
APPROPRIATE PUBLIC IT EDUCATION.
TO PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
BUT IN SPITE OF THIS MANDATE NO
STATE FUNDING IS ALLOCATED FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
THIS IS SHORT SIGHTED BECAUSE
EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAMS FOR
PRESCHOOLERS IS AN EXCELLENT
INVESTMENT.
FINALLY THE BILL PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS WITH MORE SEVERE
DISABILITIES.
WHEN OUR CURRENT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FINANCE SYSTEM WAS
ESTABLISHED WE HAD SUPPORT BUT
IT WAS ELIMINATED DURING THE
RECESSION?
LEAVING SCHOOLS WITH NO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
HIGHER COSTS PLACEMENTS.
ALL OF THE ADJUSTMENTS IN THIS
BILL ARE COMMONSENSE INVESTMENTS
IN FAIRNESS AND QUALITY FOR OUR
VALUED STUDENTS.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IS
CAROL MILLS FROM THE FRESNO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD OF
EDUCATION.
AND JENNIFER BAKER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
GOOD MORNING CAROL MILLS BOARD
MEMBER IT FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THANK YOU FOR
HEARING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
BRIEFLY MY DISTRICT HAS OVER
SEVENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS AND
OVER NINE THOUSAND OF THOSE
STUDENTS QUALIFY FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES.
WE HAVE 88% OF OUR STUDENTS
LIVING IN POVERTY.
FRESNO UNIFIED OFFERS EVERY
SPECIAL EDUCATION PROGRAM TO
SERVE ALL IDENTIFIED
DISABILITIES AND THAT INCLUDES
TWO SCHOOLS THAT SERVE JUST THE
MEDICALLY FRAGILE STUDENTS IN
OUR DISTRICT.
AND WE HAVE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MEDICALLY FRAGILE
STUDENTS.
OUR SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
RATE FROM THE STATE IS FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN DOLLARS PER
STUDENT.
THERE ARE SIXTY FOUR CELEBUZZ
THAT GET MORE MONEY AS MUCH AS
NINE HUNDRED PER STUDENT.
THERE ARE SIXTY SIX THAT GET
LESS.
AS LITTLE AS FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
DOLLARS PER STUDENT AND THERE IS
NO RATIONAL BASIS FOR THE
DISPARITY.
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA HAS PROVIDED
CALL WAS FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
IT HAS NOT KEPT PACE WITH THE
INCREASED COST OF PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR THE STUDENTS.
AND OUR COUNTRY LOCAL
CONTRIBUTIONS SOMETIMES REFERRED
TO AS AN ENCROACHMENT HAS
TRIPLED OVER THE PAST SIX YEARS.
AND THE TWENTY THIRD TWELVE
TWENTY THIRD.
FRESNO IS CUT LOCAL CONTRIBUTION
WAS TWENTY FOUR MILLION.
THIS YEAR IN THE SEVENTY ONE
MILLION.
PART OF THE INCREASE IN THE
CONTRIBUTION IS TO SERVE
PRESCHOOLERS WE ARE MANDATED TO
SERVE THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS
WITH DISABILITIES.
BUT THERE IS NO STATE FUNDING
FOR THIS MANDATE.
THERE HAS ALSO BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE STATE WIDE
IN STUDENTS IDENTIFIED AS BEING
ON THE AUTISM SPECTRUM.
IT HAS JUMPED FROM SINGLE DIGITS
TO DOUBLE DIGITS AROUND 13%.
WE ALSO CHARGE WAS SERVING
PLACEMENT AND THAT IS EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE.
A SPECIALIZED PLACEMENT THAT IS
RESIDENTIAL.
CAN COSTA DISTRICT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR PER
STUDENT.
FRESNO HAS SIX STUDENTS IN THAT
TYPE OF PLACEMENT.
WE HAVE. THIRTY STUDENTS IN
SPECIAL PLACEMENTS THAT COST IS
FIFTY THOUSAND PER YEAR.
AND THE SMALLER DISTRICTS HAVE
THESE EXPENSES AS WELL IT
TOTALLY HAPPENS THEIR BUDGET.
SO WE WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI.
FOR TWENTY EIGHT GOOD MORNING AT
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON MY
NAME IS JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
ULTIMATELY THIS SYSTEMIC LACK OF
FISCAL SUPPORT FROM THE STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION HAS LED TO A
REDUCTION IN THE SUPPORT
SERVICES ARE TEACHERS NEEDS SUCH
AS COACHING AND MENTORING ALSO
THE TIME AND RESOURCES TO BUILD
A LONG STROKE.
Là STRONG LOCAL PROGRAM SOME OF
OUR TEACHERS FACE REGULAR TURN
OVER WITH AN AVERAGE OF THREE
YEARS TO SEIZE TEACHING
ASSIGNMENTS ARE CHALLENGING.
GAPS IN RESOURCES HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY NOTEWORTHY.
RECENTLY DUBLIN WAS GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF A NEW
CURRICULAR ADOPTION ONE OF OUR
TEACHERS KNEW SHE NEEDED
SUPPLEMENTAL RESOURCES TO ENSURE
HER STUDENTS HAD ACCESS TO
STANDARDS ALIGNED INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS.
BUT THOSE SUBMIT RESOURCES WERE
NOT PART OF A PILOT HER DISTRICT
WAS USING WHAT SHE FOUND WAS
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS ORDERING
NEW MATERIALS FROM THE APPROVED
ADOPTION IS EXPENSIVE.
WHILE GENERAL EDUCATION TEACHERS
RECEIVE THE CLASS SAID IN A
TEACHER'S ASSISTANT ADDITION AS
A SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER SHE
NEEDS MULTIPLE GRADE LEVELS OF
BOTH THE TEACHER AND STUDENT
RESOURCES.
THE COST OF A GENERAL EDUCATIONS
TEACHER COUNTED FOR BUT THE
COMPLEX COSTA SPECIAL EDUCATION
NEEDS ARE OFTEN NOT FACTORED
INTO FINAL BILLS.
EFFORTS TOWARDS FULL OF
INCLUSION ADDITIONALLY AT ALL
LEVELS GENERATES MORE CHALLENGES
TO ADDRESS THE CHRONIC CAPS IN
THE FUNDING NEEDED TO ENSURE IT
IS DONE SUCCESSFULLY.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL TEACHERS ARE TRAINED IN THE
VARIOUS DISABILITIES IN THE
SUPPORTS NEEDED FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS BUT HOW CAN YOU TREAT A
TEACHER WHO ALREADY HAS A
CASELOAD OF A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PLUS STUDENT CONTRACTS DAILY.
HOW CAN YOU ENSURE THE LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS ARE MET WITHOUT THE
TIME TRAINING A STAFFING
CURRICULAR RESOURCES TO DO SO?
TEACHERS HAVE LITTLE TRAINING
TIME FOR TRAINING AND MINIMAL IF
ANY RESOURCES OR SET ASIDE FOR
TEACHER DRIVEN PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
THIS IS WHY THE NEED FOR A
BEFORE TWENTY IS SO CRITICAL.
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB FOR TWENTY EIGHT
AND TO HELP FILL THE FISCAL GAP
OR SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS
NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
THANK YOU --
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY.
GOOD IN OUR STATE GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS DAVID TOSS AND I'M
THE CHAIR OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE FUNDING IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND ESCO CO SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL WE HARDLY GET YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY PLEASE.
DAVID TOSSING COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE FUNDING IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND MORE IN FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL SAYS THERE ON BEHALF OF
FORTY SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR
SELF IS IN THE COUNTY OFFICE IN
KERN IN SUPPORT.
LIZ BUT THAT'S CANNELLA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE ARE PROUD
CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
KATHY RAVEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
AS A CO OPS CO SPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU.
STEVE WARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FUNDING
COALITION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
JEFF PARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS ON THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENTS
OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
ROBERT PIERCE WITH THE ELK GROVE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
KATIE BABCOCK DIRECTOR NORTH
REGION SELL SELL BOOKS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB.
FOUR TO EIGHT HELLO REQUESTED --
DIRECTOR SPECIAL EDUCATION FOR
PIEDMONT UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTANCE
WRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING PAMELA GIVES%
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THE TAMALE THOMAS LOS ANGELES
COUNTY CHARTER SALPA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LARA GONZALEZ YUBA COUNTY SALPA
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DR FRANCES GUERRILLAS YUBA
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOLS IN
STRONG SUPPORT A BILL FOR TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU.
OKAY DEV CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION STANDING FOR
ALL STUDENTS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
BARBARA BLOOM FOR MENDOCINO
COUNTY SELF IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
CRISTINA MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF
THE HUMBOLDT IN PLASTER COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION THE SENIOR
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PRIVATE SCHOOL --
PRIVATE SPECIAL EDUCATION
SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT THANKS.
NICK ROMAN ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY DISTRICT
ADVOCATES FOR BETTER SCHOOLS AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
AND THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION IN SUPPORT.
DANIELLE MAILLET CALIFORNIA
LINES OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
ADAM STEIN SNOW COUNTY SELFLESS
NUMBER COUNTY CHARTER SILVA IN
REALLY REALLY REALLY STRONG
SUPPORT.
ALICE KESSLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CELL BUT ADMINISTRATORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
AND ONLY SOLANO COUNTY SILVA AND
PARENT OF A CHILD WITH
DISABILITIES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
CENTER BORRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
PAULA DEEN ON BEHALF OF THE SIX
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OF THE GREATER
ANAHEIM SO BUT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KIND A COMMENCEMENT ON BEHALF OF
THE THIRTY TWO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SHASTA COUNTY CELLPHONE STRONG
SUPPORT.
JENNIFER PARKER IN THE HEALTH OF
THE ELDORADO SELFLESS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KATHY MCBRIDE REPRESENTING
ACCIDENTS.
FOR RIVER NOW WITH CALIFORNIA
GOT THE CONFERENCE STRONG
SUPPORT.
AMY LAMBERT'S SUBDIRECTOR TUSTIN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT STRONG
SUPPORT.
MIGHT I'LL GET A SANTA ANA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON
SUPPORT.
RENEE GRAY ON BEHALF OF
NORTHEAST ORANGE COUNTY SELVA
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
FOR TWENTY EIGHT CANDY PLAY HE
ON BEHALF OF PLACENTA YOU'RE
BELINDA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND PARENTS OF SPECIAL EDUCATOR.
A SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH ANGLE CONSIDER
COUNTIES HELP ON BEHALF OF
FIFTEEN ALLEY A STRONG SUPPORT.
CINDY CHANDLER FAMILY SOUP
SERVING YOU THE SATURN COLUSA
COUNTIES AND APPARENT STRONG
SUPPORT.
NEED A FISHER GRADUATE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DIAMOND FISHER OF I'M S. IF YOU
IF THE STUDENT I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
ALITA FISHER CHAIR OF THE
COMMUNITY ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION PARENT OF FOR
STUDENTS IN SF UST TO FROM JUST
SPOKE AND I STRONGLY CAN'T
EMPHASIZE STRONGLY ENOUGH
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
VERONICA CODE SUBDIRECTOR FOR TO
HIM A COUNTY AS ALFA ARE
COMPRISED OF FOURTEEN ELEAZAR
AND CONSIDERED UNNECESSARY SMALL
AND SPARSE SABA STRONG SUPPORT.
KELLY YOUNG WERE MINE FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER SERVING TWENTY
SIX COUNTIES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOR SPECIAL ED
STUDENTS AND A PARENT OF A CHILD
WITH A IN SPECIAL ED STRONG
SUPPORT.
MELANIE I CANNOT ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE MCANDREW IT ON BEHALF
OF THE TORRANCE UNIFIED AND
CLOVIS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
A SCENE OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS
FROM ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISS
SMITH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AT ONCE
AGAIN I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS CRITICALLY
TIMELY BILL I'M HAVING JUST
FINISHED NINE YEARS ON A LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD AND KNOWING THE
COST ASSOCIATED WITH PROVIDING.
NOT ONLY A SIMPLE SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM BUT A SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM THAT REALLY
ADDRESSES THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM OF ISSUES --
AND THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS THAT THIS COULDN'T BE MORE
TIMELY AN ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY --
ON BEHALF OF THE THE SELF AS
THAT I REPRESENT ALONE THERE'S
NEARLY TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
THAT CAN BE ALLOCATED TO SPECIAL
ED SERVICES.
AND SO I I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THIS I YOU HAVE I'M
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDED SPECIAL
EDUCATION AT THE PRESCHOOL LEVEL
BECAUSE OF WHAT MANY PEOPLE MAY
NOT REALIZE IS THAT.
IF WE ENGAGE THE SPECIAL ED
STUDENT POPULATION AND THEIR
FAMILIES AT THE PRESCHOOL LEVEL
AND START WITH INTERVENTION
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS AS EARLY
AS THAT AGE THERE ARE GREAT
SUCCESSES TO BE HAD AND THEY'RE
GREAT COSTS. TO BE SAVED ALONG
THE CONTINUING PATH OF THEIR
SPECIAL EDUCATION JOURNEY SO
INCLUDING NOT WAS --
REALLY WISE ON YOUR BEHALF AND I
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU DID THAT
THANK YOU.
I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY THANK
YOU I'M OF THE BILL FIRST BILLS
BEEN MOVED IN SPEND SECONDED BY
MISS SMITH.
YES AND THEN I I ALSO AND AND
STRONG SUPPORTER THIS I KNOW WE
HAD A HEARING ON THIS. FOR THOSE
OF US LAST YEAR.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
SPECIAL ANSWERS THERE IS DEBATE
WHETHER OR NOT --
WE HOW WE GOT TO SPENDING SO
MUCH OF OUR DISCUSSION MAN
SPECIAL ED BUT IT IS WHAT IT IS
AND THIS IS THE MOST APPROPRIATE.
AND EQUITABLE AND EFFECTIVE WAY.
TO BOOST AT SPECIAL LET FUNDING
THAT THAT HELPS DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS WHY WE SAW.
THE LINE OUT THE DOOR I HEARING
HERE IN MY STOCK --
ROUGHLY 10215% OF THE POPULATION
OUR SPECIAL ED IDENTIFIED
STUDENTS BUT IT REPRESENTS OVER
20% OF THE GENERAL FUND MONEY
THAT THEY SPENT AND SO.
IT'S IN IT'S AN INCREASED COST
AND I CONCUR THAT IF YOU HAVE --
EARLY INTERVENTIONS AND
SCREENINGS AND AND START EARLIER
WE CAN PREVENT --
SOME OF THE COST LATER DOWN THE
ROAD BUT THE REALITY IS SO MANY
OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE.
ARE STRAPPED WITH.
RETIREMENT COSTS --
CERTAINLY THE HIGH COST OF
LIVING IN A LABOR COSTS YOU KNOW
ADEQUATELY --
PAYING THEIR THEIR WORKFORCE AND
SPECIAL ED SO THIS IS ONE OF
THAT THE DRIVERS AND THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE --
RECONCILING IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS THIS YEAR AND I THINK
THAT THIS IS THE WAY WE OUGHT TO
BE SPENDING THE MONEY PUT FORTH
IN THE IN THE JANUARY BUDGET SO.
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
POLICY TO THIS COMMITTEE --
SEE NO FURTHER COMMENT I TO WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE BILL I
THINK BELIEVE I'M A CO AUTHOR ON
IT --
BECAUSE I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS SO I PUSHED IT LAST YEAR.
IT DIDN'T MAKE IT TO WHERE WE
WANTED TO GO SO I WISH YOU MORE
SUCCESS THAN I HAD LAST YEAR --
BUT AGAIN THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
ON ON ON ON THE STUDENT FRONT
BUT ALL.
SO WITH THAT MISTER MEDINA YOU
MAY CLOSE BY I THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR SUPPORT AND
FOR THE CHAIR FOR ALL THE WORK
HE'S DONE IN THIS AREA.
AS WELL AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AYE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER. FOR SURE THE BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER MEDIA [inaudible]
RIGHT.
I WILL HAVE A QUORUM WHAT WE
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IS PRESENT.
FOR THE MAIN.
AREA.
CABLE WHERE TO TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WELL WE HAVE A
QUORUM HERE --
DO I HAVE A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY A SWISS
SECOND MINISTER MCCARTY OTHER
CONSENT BILLS ARE AS FOLLOWS THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB.
FIFTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS --
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN ACR --
EIGHT I DON'T BELIEVE THAT HAS
MET MINUTES NOW --
SO THOSE WE HAVE THAT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB FIFTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS AND
A C. R..
EIGHT O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL
AYE KILEY KILEY AYE KALRA.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER. FOR BILLS AT THE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN
ADOPTED.
I WILL NOW MOVE I DON'T SEE
MISTER BERMAN OUT THERE BUT I DO
SEE MISS EGGMAN.
YOU MAY PERCEIVE AN READY MISS
EGGMAN HAS --
AB THREE NINETY SIX FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN WHEN PEOPLE WRITE THEIR
NAMES ARE VIA THE HEALTH OF THE
RATHER LEGIBLE TO ME.
I'M NOT SO I DO SEE EGGMAN THE
YEARS ME VERY CLEAN OKAY SOME
OTHERS I'M NOT POINTING YOU OUT
OKAY.
BUT BERMAN I MEAN I CAN'T EVEN
READ HIS NAME UP BEYOND.
THIS DOWN HERE ON A WHO NEVER
MINUTES I DON'T KNOW.
RIGHT WELL GOOD MORNING I'M HERE
AND HERE I AM.
SO GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB.
THREE NINETY SIX MINUTES FOLKS
KNOW I A I A COME FROM A SOCIAL
WORK BACKGROUND.
I TAUGHT AT SEX STATE I KNOW THE
THE WORK THAT GOES INTO
PRODUCING.
SUCH WORKERS PREPARED TO WORK IN
SCHOOL CHILD IN.
IN STOCK AND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE FIFTH GRADE AND
I SEE DALY THE STRUGGLES THAT
PARENTS FACE AND STUDENTS FACE --
MY STRONG BELIEF AND I'VE BEEN
TRYING TO WORK ON THIS FOR YEARS
IS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A SOCIAL
WORKER AND EVERY TITLE ONE
SCHOOL IN THE STATE --
SCHOOL KILTER DO ONE JOB BUT I
THINK SOCIAL COULD HAVE BEEN
MUCH DIFFERENT HOLISTIC A
BACKGROUND AND SIDE BY SIDE WITH
THEM THEY CAN ADDRESS ISSUES
THAT THE FAMILY HAS AT HOME.
ISSUES AROUND BOWLING ISSUES
AROUND SOCIAL ECONOMIC ISSUES
REFERRALS --
SO THIS YEAR --
I'VE COME BACK AGAIN RATHER TRY
TO GET ONE IN EVERY SCHOOL --
TO TRY TO SAY LET'S TRY A PILOT
LET'S TRY A PILOT A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROJECT IN SIX COUNTIES
THAT ARE ALL AROUND THE STATE SO
WE HIT EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC --
TO BE ABLE TO SAY IF WE GET ONE
IN THOSE SCHOOLS AND OF THEIR
OUTCOMES BECOME BETTER.
THEN THAT WOULD BE A BETTER
SELLING POINT FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO TO TO TO GET A
BETTER USE OF THEIR DOLLARS TO
ADOPT SOCIAL WORKERS INTO AN
ORDINARY.
THING THAT THEY DO WHEN THEY
THINK ABOUT HIRING.
WE KNOW WE'VE GIVEN SCHOOL
DISTRICT A LOT MORE LEEWAY TO BE
ABLE TO DECIDE WHAT KIND OF
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO HIRE WHAT
KIND OF POSITIONS BASED ON THEIR
OWN -- THEIR
OWN NEEDS BUT WE FEEL LIKE WE
SELLING POINT --
SO WE FEEL LIKE THIS IS A A GOOD
WAY TO GET SOCIAL WORKERS INTO
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WE'RE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO BE ABLE
TO SEE THEIR VALUE AND HOPEFULLY
BE ABLE TO HELP ALL OF OUR KIDS
DO BETTER --
IN THEIR EDUCATIONAL ENDEAVORS
WITH ME HERE TODAY I HAVE
REBEKAH GONZALEZ FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS.
GREAT THANK YOU I'M.
I'M REBECCA FROM NSW WE'RE VERY
STE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SPELLING WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING AT THE
PILOT PROGRAM FOR SCHOOL SOCIAL
WORKERS CREATED BY THIS BILL
WILL IMPROVE THE DELIVER LIKE IT
DID DELIVERY OF CRITICALLY
NEEDED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR OUR STUDENTS --
IN FACT 40% OF AMERICAN CHILDREN
ARE AT RISK FOR SCHOOL FAILURE
FAILURE DUE TO POVERTY RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IMMIGRATION
LANGUAGE BARRIERS.
LIVING IN A SINGLE PARENT FAMILY
AND PARENTS WITH LITTLE
EDUCATION OR HEALTH PROBLEMS
ABOUT 19% OR ONE IN.
FIVE I'M OF ALL CHILDREN SEEM BY
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS HAVE
BEHAVIORAL AND EMOTIONAL
PROBLEMS BUT FEW RECEIVE HELP IN
FACT FEWER THAN ONE INFIVE
NEEDING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
ACTUALLY RECEIVE THEM
ADDITIONALLY ONE OF FIVE
CHILDREN IN THE U. S. LIVE IN
POVERTY.
IN THE SCHOOL SCHOOL SOCIAL
WORKERS HELP TEACHERS STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES OVERCOME BARRIERS
TO LEARNING SCHOOL SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES THAT PROMOTE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL.
AND BEHAVIORAL ADJUSTMENT IN
SCHOOL AND IN SOCIETY SCHOOL
SOCIAL WORKERS ALSO HELP CONNECT
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
CRITICAL SUPPORT SUCH AS FOOD
AND SHELTER.
IN ADDITION SCHOOL SOCIAL
WORKERS GET CONFLICT RESOLUTION
AND ANGER MANAGEMENT HELPING
STUDENTS LEARN SOCIAL SKILLS AND
HELP PREVENT PULLING BEHAVIOR.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH SO SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS
IN THE SCHOOLS OF FOR EXAMPLE
LOCALLY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
FOLSOM CORDOVA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT ONLY HAD TO SCHOOL
SOCIAL WORKERS FOR NINETEEN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS. FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION SINGLE
OPPOSITIONAL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
MISS MISS EGGMAN --
THIS IS --
WHAT I PREACH ABOUT THIS BILL IS
MATURE IT'S NOT FULL IT'S
APPROPRIATE IT'S CALLED --
FOR SAYS IF YOU'RE NOT READY TO
ME.
SO SO OFTEN WITH SO MANY TIMES
YOU GET BILLS UP IS A WELL EVERY
SCHOOL HAS TO HAVE THIS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS JUST.
IT'S NOT DOABLE FOR THE SNAP OF
A FINGER YET THIS PROBABLY
THROUGH A BUDGET ALLOCATION OF
THE YOU KNOW THE EXERCISE DOWN
THE ROAD.
IS SOMETHING THAT'S DOABLE I WE
DO HAVE TO AMENDMENTS ONCE BEAST
ELIGIBILITY AND THE OTHER SPEAKS
TO THE EVALUATION METRICS
EVALUATING THE METRICS UPON
COMPLETION OF THE PATENT.
I BELIEVE YOU EXILES IMMENSELY
EXCEPT THOSE AND THANK YOU CAN
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK.
GREAT BOB AGAIN I A AND I AYE I
THINK YOU SHOULD JUST AS WE HEAD
DOWN THE PATH OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
A YOU SHOULD THINK ABOUT THE
ROLE THE SCHOOL COUNSELOR VERSUS
I AM THE SCHOOL COUNSELOR WOULD
PROBABLY BE MORE.
ENGAGED IN INTERNAL SMALL FORCES
AND THE SOCIAL WORKER WOULD BE
EXTERNAL TERM SCHOOL FORCES --
BUT EITHER WAY I I'M COFFEE
YOU'LL DO THAT BECAUSE YOU GET
IT.
SO WITH THAT I THANK YOU ANY
OTHER AND IT ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISS SMITH.
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR I AM
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS PILOT
PROGRAM AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE TRIED IN THE DISTRICT THAT I
JUST LEFT AND FOR MANY FAMILIES.
A SCHOOL IS THEIR POINT OF
CONTACT WITH GOVERNMENT AND
GOVERNMENT SERVICES AND
PARTICULARLY FOR CHALLENGED
FAMILIES THIS MAY BE THE BEST
MEANS OF CONNECTING THEM TO
THOSE OUTSIDE SERVICES THAT
MEANS SO MUCH TO THE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING OF THEIR
CHILD SO.
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE
AUTHORED DOES LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GREAT THANK
YOU YOU MAY CLOSE --
JUST THAT THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND THANK THE CHAIR FOR AND THE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR INVESTMENT IN
THIS AND MANY OF US JUST WENT
DOWN -- TO A
PRISON DOWN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND YOU KNOW WHAT
WITHOUT A DOUBT EVERYBODY EVERY
INMATE WE TALK TO TALK ABOUT THE
STRUGGLES AT SCHOOL HOME LIFE.
WE KNOW WHERE THAT PATH GOES
WHEN I WAS AT PORTLAND STATE I'D
THEY HAVE ORGAN HAS EVEN OF MUCH
HEALTHIER SCHOOL SOCIAL WORK
PRESENTS --
AND KIND AMOUNT OF HOME VISITS
PEOPLE WERE DOING CONNECTING
FAMILIES TO RESOURCES I THINK
JUST JUST CAN BE THAT SAFETY
BLOCK AS MISSPENT TALKED ABOUT A
TO KEEP FAMILIES THAT MIGHT BE
TIPPING ON THE DGE TO A PATH OF
HEALTHINESS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ABOUT GREAT THANK YOU I MISS
SMITH ALL SECOND --
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY KALRA.
MCCARTY SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
THE BILL HAS TO VOTED IS ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WELL NOW MOVES --
TO MR OBERNOLTE.
WHO'S BEEN VERY PATIENT --
IS HE HAS AB TWENTY EIGHT WHICH
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE THERE IS A CRITICAL
NEED FOR STUDENTS WHO HAVE
EDUCATION AND THE SO CALLED STEM
FIELDS IN CALIFORNIA THOSE BEING
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING
AND MATHEMATICS.
IT'S BEEN ESTIMATED THAT IN THE
NEXT TEN YEARS GROWTH IN JOBS
WITHIN THOSE FIELDS WILL BE OVER
19% AND IN FACT THAT OVER HALF
OF THE NEW JOBS CREATED IN
CALIFORNIA WILL BE IN THE STEM
FIELDS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE NOT
DOING A GOOD JOB A PROPERLY
PREPARING STUDENTS TO ENTER
THOSE FIELDS IN FACT LAST YEAR
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES.
THAT OVER TWICE AS MANY NEW JOBS
WERE AVAILABLE IN THOSE FIELDS
AS THERE WERE UNEMPLOYED WORKERS
IN THOSE FIELDS LOOKING FOR JOBS.
SO WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
PREPARING STUDENTS FOR THOSE
FIELDS THIS BILL AB TWENTY EIGHT
IS AN EFFORT TO DO JUST THAT.
THIS WOULD CREATE A STEM A SEAL
FOR HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS IN AN
EFFORT TO INCENTIVIZE STUDENTS
TO ENTER INTO STUDIES IN THOSE
FIELDS.
SO ELIGIBILITY FOR THIS SEAL
WOULD BE FIRST OF ALL --
OPT IN ON PART OF THE SCHOOL TO
ON THEIR OWN WHETHER NOT TO
PARTICIPATE BUT A STUDENT WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO TO TAKE FOUR
YEARS OF SCIENCE. FOUR YEARS OF
MATHEMATICS ONE OF WHICH CAN BE
A COMPUTER SCIENCE AND ACHIEVE
CERTAIN BENCHMARKS IN THOSE
FIELDS A MINIMUM OF THREE POINT
OH GPA IN THOSE CLASSES --
AND THEN PROVE PROFICIENCY IN
THOSE FIELDS ON GRADUATION
THROUGH EITHER A ON SAT SUBJECT
SCORE AN AP TEST SCORE SEVERAL
OTHER --
METHODOLOGIES FOR DEMONSTRATING
PROFICIENCY SO ARE MISTER CHAIR
I WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK AND THE
WORK WITH US ON THIS BILL AND
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TO
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THANK YOU --
YOUR WITNESS.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE SEE THIS BILL AS
A WAY TO PROVIDE STUDENTS.
I GUESS WITH AN INCENTIVE WITH --
A A TANGIBLE SHOWING THAT
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO SUCCEED IN
THE STEM PROGRAM THEY'VE CHOSEN
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL --
IT WOULD PROVIDE THEM WITH AN
ABILITY TO AND TO BE ABLE TO
MARKET THEMSELVES POTENTIALLY TO
FOR THEIR YOU KNOW FUTURE
EMPLOYERS MAYBE EVEN THROUGH THE
COLLEGE TRACK.
SO WE DO SUPPORT THE MEASURE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH BROWN ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW WE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
FOR ENCOURAGING AND AND
PROMOTING STEM EDUCATION THANK
YOU. THREE OTHERS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFITT ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES IN SUPPORT.
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
KATHY RAVEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION --
CENA OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OVER
IMPACTS THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THE SPENT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
THANK YOU OUR COLLEAGUE FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I DO
THINK IT IS ESSENTIAL --
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS THE
NEW REALITY WITH OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT NEEDS AND HAVING
SOMETHING THAT INSPIRES STUDENTS
TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR STEM
PROGRAMS --
REGARDLESS HOW WE GET THERE --
IS WORTH LOOKING AT MY BIGGEST
CONCERN IN THINKING ABOUT THIS
MEASURE THAT WAS IT I KNOW THAT
WE STILL HAVE A NUMBER OF
DISTRICT STATE WIDE WHERE.
THE DEPTH AND BREADTH OF THE
COURSES REQUIRED TO GET THE SEAL
MAY NOT BE READILY OR EASILY
AVAILABLE COULD YOU SPEAK TO
THAT ISSUE PLEASE CERTAINLY THAT
WAS THIS IS OUR SECOND YEAR
TRYING TO GET THIS BILL THROUGH
A LAST YEAR WAS HELD IN
APPROPRIATIONS AND I THINK WE
HAVE.
A PATH THROUGH THE COMMITTEE NOW.
THIS COMMITTEE HAD THAT CONCERN
WITH THE BILL LAST YEAR AND A TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS WE TOOK
AMENDMENTS LAST YEAR THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION TO ADOPT CERTAIN
FINDINGS BEFORE THE SEAL WAS
CREATED AND AMONG THOSE FINDINGS.
ARE FINDING THAT ALL STUDENTS TO
CALIFORNIA HAD REASONABLY EQUAL
ACCESS TO THAT SEAL.
SO.
I'M HOPING THAT THAT ADDRESSES
THE CONCERN BUT ALSO IN A LARGER
SENSE -- THE
PURPOSE OF THE SEAL IS TO
INCENTIVIZE NOT ONLY STUDENTS
BUT ALSO SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
HAVE THIS CURRICULUM AVAILABLE.
ANSWER HOPING THAT THE SEAL
SHEDS LITTLE MAYBE THOSE CLASSES
ARE NOT AVAILABLE AND THEN
MOTIVATES THEM TO MOVE TOWARDS
GETTING THOSE CLASSES AVAILABLE
SO THAT ALL STUDENTS WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO THEM.
THANK YOU --
A SINGLE FOR THE COMMON FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO EMOTION.
MOVE TO QUE MOVED SECONDED ALL
SECOND --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA
MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
THE BILL IS ON CALL HAS CHIU
VOTES THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU.
I WILL THAT WILL MOVE TO MISTER
GALLAGHER --
BELIEVES.
KELLY AB TWO NINETY SEVEN FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT WELL I'M NUMBER
.
EIGHT WE'RE READY ARE YOU MISTER
GALLERY YOU GO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE SETTING --
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB.
TWO NINETY SEVEN YOUR MISTER
CHAIRMAN WHICH WOULD PROVIDE TO
BACK FILL OF EIGHTY EIGHT MONIES --
FOR THE SCHOOLS IN PARADISE TO
BE COUNTY THAT WERE AFFECTED BY
THE CAMPFIRE --
AND I DO HAVE WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF GO AHEAD AND LET THEM --
TESTIFY --
FIRST TO HAVE MICHELLE JOHNSON
FROM [inaudible]
AS UNIFIED.
DISTRICT AND CHAU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR O'DONNELL IN
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE JOHN AND I
AM THE SUPERINTENDENT FOR
PARADISE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK AT LAST
MONTH'S INFORMATIONAL HEARING
REGARDING THE IMPACT OF
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES ON PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
IT WAS AT THAT HEARING THAT I
LAID OUT THE OVERWHELMING
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT OUR COMMUNITY
AND OUR DISTRICT FACE.
IT WAS ALSO AT THAT HEARING WERE
EXPLAINED.
AT THE COMMITTEES THE NEED FOR
LONG TERM FINANCIAL SOLUTION TO
PROVIDE STABILITY AND SUPPORT%
FOR OUR STUDENTS AND STAFF.
AS YOU KNOW THE CAMPFIRE WAS THE
MOST DEADLY AND DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRE IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
DEVASTATING OUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY
AND SCHOOL SYSTEM.
PARADISE IS RESILIENT AND STRONG
COMMUNITY BUT THE TRUTH IS IS
THAT IT WILL TAKE MANY YEARS TO
REBUILD THE TOWN.
AND WITHOUT THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT.
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
OUR STUDENTS TEACHERS AND
FAMILIES WITH WHAT THEY NEED.
LAST OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ARE STUDENT ROMA WAS AT
THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED FAST FORWARD
TO TODAY THAT PUTS OUR MOMENT AT
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED HALF OF THE
STUDENTS HAVE LEFT THE SCHOOLS.
AND THE COMMUNITY AS A RESULT
CAN'T FIRE.
ADDITIONALLY OUR PROJECTIONS
INDICATE THAT THERE MOMENT IS
LIKELY CONTINUE TO DROP TO
TWELVE HUNDRED OR SO STUDENTS
WHEN WE RETURN TO PARADISE. FOR
THIS REASON I'M HERE TODAY
ASKING YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT
ASSEMBLYMAN GALLAGHER'S A. B.
TWO NINETY SEVEN BILL.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT OUR
DISTRICT MAINTAINS THE PRE FIRE
FUNDING LEVEL.
TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE KEEPING
THIS FINANCIALLY SOLVENT MH AND
ABLE TO MAINTAIN THE SMALL BIT
OF NORMALCY AND A STATE.
AND A STABLE DISTRICT PROVIDES.
TO BOTH ITS STUDENTS AND ITS
STAFF.
THE BILL WILL ALSO ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE OUR CURRENT EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS.
AND REMAIN COMPETITIVE FOR
TEACHER SALARIES WHEN THERE ARE
SO MANY DISINCENTIVES FOR STAFF
TO STATE.
PARADISE IS HURT ME UP WE KNOW
THAT THIS REBUILD WILL TAKE
LONGER THAN THE YEARS.
POSTED THIS LEGISLATION WE HOPE
TO CONTINUE A CONVERSATION FOR A
MULTI YEAR EIGHTY A RAMP DOWN.
PERIOD FOLLOWING THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR.
WAS SUCH AN AND PRESENT
PRESIDENT OF FIRE WE THINK IT
AND PRESIDENTE RECOVERY PLAN
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED.
I WANT TO CONCLUDE BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AND ONCE AGAIN URGE A YES VOTE
ON AB THANK NINETY SEVEN THANK
YOU.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR O'DONNELL AND
AM EDUCATION COMMITTEE MET
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GRETCHEN PACK
AND I'M A TEACHER WITH THE
PARADISE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND I WILL TRY TO HOLD IT
TOGETHER.
SIX I'M I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION PARADISE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL WHO'S PASSING WILL
PROVIDE US WITH AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR OF FISCAL READ.
FISCAL RELIEF DURING THE
REBUILDING PROCESS FOLLOWING THE
NOVEMBER EIGHTH CAMPFIRE.
GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
REBUILDING EFFORTS IN CHALLENGES
IN SANTA ROSA AND READING WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED THAT THE CURRENT
THREE YEARS OF FUNDING WILL NOT
BE ENOUGH.
I WISH I HAD THE TIME TO DETAIL
WHAT MAKES OUR SCHOOLS SO
SPECIAL BUT THE MAIN INGREDIENTS.
OUR TEACHERS SUPPORT STAFF AND
STUDENTS.
TEACHERS SAY THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS THAT DAY.
THEY QUICKLY AND CALMLY HELPED
EVACUATE.
OVER 90% OF OUR SCHOOL.
HOWEVER THERE WERE TWENTY TWO
STUDENTS LEFT TO RIGHT IN THE
EVACUATION BUS OUT OF TOWN TO
SAFETY. ONE OF MY SECOND GREAT
TEACHING PARTNERS.
AND OUR NEWEST KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER WELCOME TO TEACHING --
I RODE WITH THEM THROUGH FLAMES
AND SMOKE.
AT ONE POINT THE STUDENTS BECAME
SLEEPY DUE TO THE SMOKE IN THE
BOX.
SERVICE TEACHERS TOOK TURNS
CONSULTING STUDENTS AS THEY HELD
WHAT PIECES OF THE BUS DRIVER
SHIRT OVER THEIR MOUTHS.
MORE THAN ONE OF OUR TEACHERS
HAD TO RUN FROM THE FLAMES WHEN
THEIR CARS WERE STUCK IN
GRIDLOCK TRAFFIC. ONE EVEN STOOD
WITH A GROUP OF PEOPLE CIRCLED
BY FIRE ENGINES.
AND HOSE DOWN WITH WATER AS
BURNING EMBERS.
RUNNING DOWN ON THEM.
SEC.
IT WAS A TRACK TRAUMATIC AS
EXPERIENCE FOR US ALL.
DESPITE THESE EXPERIENCES
TEACHERS FAMILIES AND STUDENTS
WANT TO COME BACK TO PARADISE
AND AT SCHOOLS AND WE WANT TO BE
THERE READY TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
A QUALITY EDUCATION THEY HAVE
HAD AND DESERVE TO CONTINUE
HAVING.
OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGE IS HOW TO
KEEP.
OUR AMAZING DEDICATED AND
QUALIFIED STAFF THAT WE ARE
KNOWN FOR WE CAN ONLY DO THIS IF
TEACHERS KNOW THAT THEY WILL
HAVE JOB TO COME BACK TO NEXT
YEAR AND THE YEARS TO FOLLOW
DURING THE REBUILDING PROCESS.
MANY OF US FEAR THAT A COUPLE OF
YEARS OF GUARANTEEING GUARANTEED
FUNDING WILL NOT BE ENOUGH TO
SUSTAIN STAFFING NEEDS.
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT POSSIBLE
DOWNSIZING LEAVE US WORRIED
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF OUR DISTRICT
AND MAJOR DECISIONS THAT MAY BE --
PREMATURE.
AND NOT MERE LONG TERM NEEDS
WHAT WE NEED FROM THIS
LEGISLATURE IS THE ASSURANCE
THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL
WITH AN UNDERSTANDING OF THE
OVERWHELMING DEVASTATION.
AND KNOW THAT ALTHOUGH OUR
SPIRITS ARE HIGH AND HOPE IS
ALIVE OUR HEARTS ARE STILL
BROKEN AND MENDING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT JUST A QUICK ME TO
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL
YODER SCHEIDER INTO YOUNG WE
HAVE THE BIãU COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IF EVER A COMMUNITY
DESERVED A BILL LIKE THIS IT'S
PARADISE.
BOB I AGREE.
UP IN UP JUST TECHNOLOGY --
WORK MISTER GALLAGHER ON THIS
EFFORT BECAUSE YOU'VE DONE I
THINK YOU'VE DONE A I KNOW
YOU'VE GOT YOU'RE KIDDING.
YOUR FELLOW MEMBERS AS TO THE
IMPACT OF THIS DISASTER ON THE
COMMUNITY WE WENT UP THERE RIGHT
AND THE SUPERINTENDENT WAS --
AMONGST OTHERS AND WE TOURED THE
AREA.
AND WAS CERTAINLY LIKE NOTHING
LIKE I'D EVER SEEN.
SO I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR
WORK IN EDUCATING THE OTHER
LEGISLATORS SO WE CAN SUPPORT
EFFORTS LIKE THIS.
TODAY.
I JUST WANT TO JUMP IN A
KNOWLEDGE YOUR WORK AND AND AND
THE OTHERS TO SUPERINTEND THOSE
TEACHERS.
THE WHOLE COMMUNITY YOU KNOW I I
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT YOU'RE
GOING THROUGH --
HAVING SEEN WHAT I WHAT I DID
WHEN I WENT UP THERE WITH YOU
NOT TOO LONG AGO SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR EFFORTS --
WITH THAT WILL GO BACK TO THOSE
AND OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JOHN LINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
CESSATION SUPPORT.
KEVIN MCRAE REPRESENTING ACCENTS
SUPPORT.
CRISTINA MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF
THE CINEMA COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT.
THERE CENTER WE HAVE THE BUTTE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
SUPPORT.
RUNNING A CODES TO HIM A COUNTY
AS ALFA AND BUTTE COUNTY
RESIDENTS STRONG SUPPORT.
ERIC OFTEN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
LARA GONZALEZ YUBA COUNTY SALPA
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OF THE ANY ANY
OPPOSITION.
GOOD -- WITH
THAT COMES FROM COMMITTEE --
MISS SMITH.
THANK YOU THANK THE AUTHOR AND
PARTICULARLY THE EDUCATION
PROFESSIONALS FROM YOUR
COMMUNITY WHO HAVE COME TO
SACRAMENTO NOW TIME AND AGAIN
AND SO DILIGENTLY ADVOCATING ON
BEHALF OF YOUR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND WITH THAT MISTER
TERRY MOVE THE BILL.
AND I'LL SECOND THE VILLAGE WHEN
I MAKE COULD YOU DID ACCEPT THE
MM SEARCH TO AMENDMENTS. ONE
SPEAKS TO CHARTER SCHOOLS BEING
OPERATIONAL ACTIVELY EDUCATING
STUDENTS.
AND THE OTHER SPEAKS TO THE
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE FOR NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
YOU ACCEPT AS A MEMBER THAT WE
DO ACCEPT THOSE MOMENTS AND I DO
JUST.
VERY QUICKLY MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US
YOU KNOW AS YOU SAID YOU WENT UP
THERE WITH US --
TO PARADISE SAW THE DEVASTATION
AND YOU'VE BEEN COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH ME THROUGHOUT THOSE
KIDS HAVE A STABLE CONTINUED
EDUCATION UP THERE AND AND I
HAVE SO I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
YOUR WORK IN THE COMMITTEES WORK.
ON THIS BILL IN AND I THINK
MAKING IT A STRONGER AND BETTER
BILL GOING FORWARD SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
THAT -- WILL
CALL THE ROLL THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
AND THE AGAIN THE M. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL I'VE
DONE ALL I KILEY.
KALRA MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THE BILL IS REVOKED SO
IT IS ON CALL NEEDS ONE MORE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
WE'LL NOW MOVE [inaudible]
MR.
MISTER BERMAN'S NOT HERE --
MISTER CHIU.
IS RIGHT THERE HE IS AB EIGHT
FILE ITEM NUMBER
.
ONE YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TIME
MEMBERS OF FIRST OF ALL I WANNA
THANK YOU.
THE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL ARE YOU
BE HOW HAPPILY OF SAPPY --
COME MEET ME COME COMING HERE.
THE AMENDMENT I'M HERE TO TODAY
2% A. B..
EIGHT THE BILL CAME TO PLACE ONE
OR MORE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ALL ALL K. TO
TWELVE SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
AND ESTABLISH A RACIAL.
ALL ONE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL PER.
EVERY FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS.
THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY SCHOOLS.
AS OPPOSED TO MILLER BILL PASSED
THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR.
WAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR A BI EIGHT I
AM REQUESTING NAM PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS TO
PROVIDE DIRECT FUNDING TO BRING
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT TO STUDENT.
IN CALIFORNIA THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILDREN BETWEEN AGE
FOR AN ELEVEN HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS.
DID RESEARCH TELL US EARLIER
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
SERVICES ARE CRITICAL.
HOLD EVER OVER 70% OF DEALS
CHILDREN'S NEVER RECEIVED ANY
TREATMENT.
M. FOR THE UC IMPROPER T. OR
WITH NON ENGLISH SPEAKING
PARENTS THIS NUMBER JUMPED TO
OVER 80%.
CHAU AND USE FAST BY SUICIDE ARE
RISING AT THE ALARMING RATE.
AND SPECIALLY FOR GIRLS OF AGE.
TEN TO FOURTEEN OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE EXPERIENCING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS.
AND THEY NEED OUR HELP.
SCHOOL HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED ESTA
BAST SETTING TO PROVIDE SERVICES.
ESPECIALLY FOR REACHING STUDENTS
OF COLOR AND UNDERS.
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER CURRENT STUDENTS TO PRO
PERU OF A SUPPORT STAFF RACIAL
ARE REALLY TOO HIGH TO PROVIDE
TIME THE SERVICES.
THE TEACHERS WHO ARE OFTEN THE
FIRST CONTACT OF THE STUDENT.
FEEL ILL EQUIPPED. TO
COMMUNICATE WITH SOME ABOUT
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
AB EIGHT WILL PROVIDE A BASELINE
REQUIREMENTS. FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT IN SCHOOL FOR CHILDREN
AND USED ACROSS THE STATE.
AND I HAVE TO BE A VERY VERY
VERY HONEST I I REALLY CAN'T
TAKE CREDIT FOR THE THAT THIS
BILL FOR FOR THE IDEA.
TO COME COMING OUT WITH THIS
BILL THE IDEA ACTUALLY CAME
DIRECTLY FROM VIEWS ADVOCATING.
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT ON
THEIR BEHALF.
THROUGH THIS BILL THE THIRD TO
STAY WHAT IN VAST EMPIRE TIES
EQUITABLE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR ALL CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
AND BREAK DOWN THE BARRIERS OF
US TAKE MONTHS EXISTING TODAY.
MOVING FORWARD I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING WAS AND ENGAGE WITH
STATE THE STAKEHOLDERS ON
CONCERNS TO FIND SOLUTION.
SO WE CAN ALL MEET ALL OF
IMPROVING --
OF RESOURCES AND SUPPORT OF OUR
STUDENTS.
THIS BILL ENJOYED THE
SPONSORSHIP ALL MENTAL HEALTH
AMERICAN UP CALIFORNIA.
AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE.
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA AND
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND OTHERS.
BUT BEFORE I INTRODUCED THE I'M
A DO WITNESSES ALIKE.
TO YODA PODIUM TO MY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- EL
GORDO GARCIA WHO'S THE JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE --
MEMBERS --
WE ARE UP PRESENTING HIS BILL
THE NIGHT THANK KANSEN. FOR
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT WITH HIM AS
HE KNOWS STRICT I'D LIKE TO
TOUCH ON THE ISSUE FROM THE
CREATING A SUSTAINABLE AND SAFE
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT FOR STUDENTS --
KNOWING HOW IMPORTANT IT IS THAT
OUR STUDENTS --
AS SPENT TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
TIME.
IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS IT IS THE
IDEAL LOCATION.
UP FOR US TO WORK WITH OUR
STUDENTS AS THE SOME NUMBER CHIU
AS SAID.
YOU KNOW ONE OF WHAT FIVE ONE OF
SIX INDIVIDUALS DEALING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH.
ISSUES IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
ULTIMATELY WITHOUT IT BEING
ADDRESS CREATING A VERY.
CHALLENGING A CIRCUMSTANCE --
AS IT RELATES TO THE SAFETY AND
WELL BEING.
OF STUDENTS TEACHERS AND THE
OVERALL RULES --
SO JUST WANTED TO SUPPORT.
SOME MEMBER CHU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK THANK YOU.
A COUNTRY --
INTRODUCE SIDE OF OF THE WORK
WITNESSES.
I'M SORRY MY WITNESSES.
GIVE WALGREENS YEAH YEAH I WAS
GOING TO TURN TO THE NOW OKAY
ALL RIGHT --
DEAR DEAR TO WITNESSES SUPPORT
RIGHT --
THERE A OF FROM THE PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF A MENTAL HEALTH THE
AMERICAN OF CALIFORNIA.
THE MONK CREASON.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN DEMOCRATS THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO MENTAL HEALTH
AMERICA OF CALIFORNIA A MAJOR
THEME IN A HELP AMERICAN OF
CALIFORNIA AS A SIXTY YEAR OLD
GRASSROOTS ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON MENTAL HEALTH POLICY
ADVOCACY PUBLIC EDUCATION.
THE IDEA THAT THAT LED TO AB
EIGHT CAME FROM THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT NETWORK WHICH
IS THAT PROGRAM OF MHC.
CAYENNE'S DIRECTION AND
PRIORITIES ARE DETERMINED A 100%
MY ITS YOUTH BOARD I AGES.
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY SIX HI AND
YOUTH LEADERS IDENTIFIED HAVING
ACCESS HEAT TO THEIR ON GOING
MENTAL WELLNESS.
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
WERE YOUNG PEOPLE SPEND THE
MAJORITY OF THEIR TIME WILL BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION WHICH WE KNOW.
FOR IS PROVING TO FOSTER
POSITIVE OUTCOMES LAST NIGHT I
HEARD AN UPDATE ON IN TSS MULTI
TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT IN MY
ROLE AS GOVERNING BOARD MEMBER
FOR THE SAN JUAN UNIFIED.
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND IS ROOTED IN
THE IDENTIFICATION MILD MODEL A
100% THERE IS A ROLE FOR
IDENTIFICATION BUT THERE ARE
ENOUGH INITIATIVES THAT ARE AB
FOUND IT IN HELP SEEKING WHERE
TO FOLKS GO WHERE THE YOUNG
FOLKS GO WHEN THEY KNOW THEY
NEED HELP.
OR THEY WANT TO HELP OTHER
PEOPLE THEY CAN'T WAIT TO BE
IDENTIFIED THE NEED SOMEWHERE TO
GO.
IF WE WANT BETTER OUTCOMES WITH
OUR ADULTS WE HAVE TO DO BETTER
OF WITH OUR KIDS I CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO BE ONE OF THE
LARGEST STRONGEST ECONOMIES IN
THE WORLD YET WE'RE AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE LIST OF PER PUPIL
SPENDING AT THE TOP OF THE LIST.
FOR A PRISON AS SPENDING ON
PRISONERS WE HAVE TO DO BETTER
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR THIS COMMITTEE TO HONOR THE
YOUTH VOICING YOUTH WISH FOR
THIS SUPPORT AT SCHOOL TO FOSTER
THEIR MENTAL WELLNESS AND ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE FOR HEARING
ME TODAY MY NAME IS BACK AND I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHT IN HIGH SCHOOL I STRUGGLED
WITH MY MENTAL HEALTH AS WELL AS
ISSUES AT HOME I HAD FREQUENT
PANIC ATTACKS MOST OF WHICH
OCCUR DUE TO STRESS AT SCHOOL.
SINCE ON MY CAMPUS WE DIDN'T
HAVE A CONSISTENT MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL TEACHERS ARE OFTEN
AT A LOSS TO SEND AS TO WHERE TO
SEND STUDENTS LIKE ME.
IN FACT THERE ARE MANY YOUTH IN
MY COUNTY WHO RECOGNIZE AND ALL
HEALTH IS THERE WAS ONE OF THEIR
MAIN CONCERNS WE SURVEYED OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED YOUTH AND FOUND
THAT MORE THAN A THIRD OF THEM
HAD EXPERIENCE MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS THEMSELVES AND CONSIDER
MENTAL HEALTH ONE OF THEIR TOP.
PRIORITIES.
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL
EXPERIENCE PANIC ATTACKS I WAS
OFTEN USHERED OUT OF CLASS OF
THE PASS AND ANOTHER STUDENT IN
HOPES THAT I WOULD BE ABLE TO
WALK IT OFF SOMETIMES I WAS ALSO
SENT TO THE OFFICE TO SPEAK TO
COUNSELORS ONLY TO BE SENT RIGHT
BACK? TO CLASS SO THE
SYMPATHETIC REMARK ABOUT HOW I
COULDN'T JUST SIT IN THE OFFICE.
FOR ME THIS ONE ON MY MENTAL
HEALTH WASN'T POSSIBLE I WAS
USING VALUABLE TIME IN CLASSES
THAT I WAS ALREADY FALLING
BEHIND AND THE GREATER THE GAP
IN MY EDUCATION BECAME THE MORE
ANXIOUS I GOT UNTIL I WITHDRAW
IT AND MY MENTAL HEALTH SPIRALED
OUT OF CONTROL.
THIS EVENTUALLY LED TO ME
DROPPING OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL AND
BECOMING HOMELESS.
I'M NINETEEN YEARS OLD NOW AND
THE NUMBER OF SALAMIS VOICES.
I AM INVOLVED IN OUR LOCAL
AMATEUR SAY PROCESS HAVE STABLE
HOUSING AND I'M CURRENTLY
STUDYING TURN MY GED AND WHAT IT
TOOK TO PUT ME ON TRACK WAS FOR
SOMEONE NAMED.
NAMELY MAYES QUARTER COORDINATOR
LIST SOME THE PARTNERS THAT
EVENTUALLY HELPED ME GET THERAPY
IN THE OTHER SERVICES I NEEDED.
IF I HAD ACCESS TO THESE SORTS
OF SUPPORTS AND SERVICES THEY'RE
QUALIFIED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL ON MY SCHOOL CAMPUS
IT COULD HAVE CHANGED MY LIFE.
I DON'T BELIEVE I WOULD HAVE
DROPPED OUT OR BECOME HOMELESS I
BELIEVE THAT OF AB EIGHT PASSES
IT WILL HAVE A PROFOUND EFFECT
ON THE MANY STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA JUST LIKE ME.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING MY
TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU THE VERY REAL VERY
AUTHENTIC THANK YOU --
WITH THAT I WILL GO TO OTHER --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY.
RIVER NOW THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KATHY RAVEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA STRONG SUPPORT.
ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
NICOLE ASTORIA ON BEHALF OF THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE AND SUPPORT.
THEY HAVE ONE REPRESENTING OUR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES ARE WE
ARE IN SUPPORT IN CONCEPT
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE.
SIR MICHAEL GAS DIDN'T WITH YOU
FORWARD WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
ERICA HAVE BEEN A BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF GETTING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN THE SCHOOL
THE CONCERN WE HAVE WITH THIS.
IS THE DIRECTION OF THE FOUR
HUNDRED AND ONE RATIO AND ARE
THERE ENOUGH MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS OUT THERE. TO FILL
THOSE SLOTS IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BUT ALSO.
THE MANDATE THAT EVERY SCHOOL
HAVE TO MEET THAT MEANT THAT
REQUIREMENT --
WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
FUNDING FOR THIS WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS GOING TO BE
DOING TO REACH OUT FOR PROP NON
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS.
AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH HIS OFFICE TO DISCUSS THESE
ISSUES AND COME TO RESOLUTION ON
THEM THANK YOU.
TONY TOOK --
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ALSO
HAVE SOME MAJOR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
MORE CREDENTIALED.
THE STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES
COUNSELORS SOCIAL WORKERS NURSES
AND SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS WE
THINK OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS WERE
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES WE WOULD BE
MINIMIZING THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL NON.
CREDENTIALED PEOPLE PROVIDING
THOSE SERVICES ON CAMPUS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
ON THE BILL BUT WE HELPED
RESOLVE THIS BEFORE.
WE HAVE TO TAKE IN A POST
POSITION THANK YOU.
ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE HAVE A
CONCERN POSITION ON THE BILL --%
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE FUNDING
THERE'S NO FUNDING TO TIED TO
THE BILL SO --
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT IT IS THE
INTENT TING FOR THIS BILL
OUTSIDE OF PRIME NINETY EIGHT
THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU.
I WITHOUT ANY COMMENTS FROM ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
MISS SMITH.
AND THANK YOU AUTHORS INTO YOUR
WITNESSES ON THIS BILL WELL I
CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE ANY --
CARL AT ALL WITH THE NEED AND
THE INTENT BEHIND THIS MEASURE I
DO HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
LIKE SOME EXPRESSED HERE TODAY
ABOUT THE FUNDING MECHANISM FOR
THIS PARTICULARLY IF IT'S NON
PROP NINETY EIGHT WHETHER THIS
BECOMES AN ONGOING CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS.
AND WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE TAKING
A COMPREHENSIVE ENOUGH VIEW WITH
THE USE OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCE DOLLARS STATEWIDE IN
MAKING SURE THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
AVAILABLE AND LOCALIZED AT A
SCHOOL SITE.
SO -- YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE THE
WILLINGNESS OF ALL OF THOSE WHO
HAVE A STAKE IN THIS TO CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION THAT BEING
SAID ON THIS CONVERSATION I
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO BE AN
IF IF POSSIBLE AND IF NECESSARY.
AND SO I I MOVE THE BILL FORWARD
CERTAINLY THAT THE FISCAL
COMPONENT IN THE DELIVERY
COMPONENTS REALLY NEED TO BE
EXAMINED AND IRONED OUT.
I THINK YOU WILL TAKE THAT AS A
MOTION TO SMITH.
I WAS COLOR DO YOU YOU SECOND
THAT MOTION.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
SMITH FOR YOUR COMMENTS BECAUSE
I'LL SACK OF THOSE I SOME REAL
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FUNDING
MECHANISM.
AND ALSO JUST THE SOLE FOCUS ON
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IS
NOT THAT WE DON'T NEED THEM FOR
SURE WE DO.
BUT I THINK WE NEED A WHOLE
BEFORE IT'S MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
JUST MENTAL HEALTH --
BUT AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
CONCEPT AND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE SOIL THE SUPPORT OF
TODAY AND AGAIN I URGE YOU TO
WORK WITH SO WITH THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PRESENTED
CONCERNS HERE TODAY.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS NOW
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
CHAIR I KNOW THAT YOU ALSO HAVE
A BILL.
THEY'RE MOVING FORWARD
STREAMLINED SOME OF THE THE TOOK
TO THE PROCESS FLOW SCHOOL. TO
GET MENTAL HEALTH THE THE
BILLING.
I THINK YOU'RE TALK ABOUT THE
BILLING SPECIFICALLY ON THE
BILLING RIGHT BY SO I JUST WANT
TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK YOU AND I'LL BE HAPPY.
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU AND
BACK TO THIS BILL DOES THIS BILL
BRING SERVICES TO CHILDREN.
AND USED FOR DAY ARE PROVIDING
INVALUABLE SUPPORT FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION IN A VERY CRITICAL
POINT UP THEIR LIFE.
SO I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT I'LL BE
HAPPY TO I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO RESOLVE
THE ISSUES.
OF US BROUGHT FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SURE I'LL JUST SAY --
IT'S PROVEN THAT MENTALLY AND
THIS IS A WELL PROVEN FACT IN A
GOOD INVESTMENT.
IN OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM
RESPECT LAST RIVAL.
GREAT THANK YOU OTHER BILLS AND
MOVED AND SECONDED --
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO HELP THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO HEALTH COMMITTEE O'DONNELL HI.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER I THE BILL HAS FOR ROAD SO
IT IS OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WITH THAT WILL MOVE IS MISTER
BERMAN HERE NO MISTER BERMAN
ALISTAIR THURMAN.
NOW MR BERMAN BALLISTIC THURMAN.
OR GERMAN BUT A YEAH I KNOW
YOU'RE THE ONE TO MAKE A
STATEMENT ABOUT A PREVIOUS.
BILL.
WHICH IS ALREADY BEEN PRESENTED
AND BUT THEY DID HAVE A ROOM
THAT THAT THAT HAVE ENOUGH
CLOSER GET ON A DAY OUT TO THE
BILL'S BEEN PRESENTED AND THEN
TO PASS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND I THINK YOU WANT TO MAKE A
STATEMENT ON THAT I USE CHAIR
REGULATING ON TIME AS WELL --
I THANK YOU FOR THE I GOT LOST
ON THE WAY I FORGOT HOW THINGS
WORK IN THE BUILDING --
WE DID GET CALLED ON TO ANOTHER
MATTER BUT APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY JUST TO SAY A WORD
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE ONE
AND THANK YOU THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OF FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF IT AND
THANK YOU TO NUMBER WEBER --
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP HERE I WON'T
BELABOR THE POINT I THINK YOU
ALL UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE A
VERY DIVERSE STATE AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT CAN BE FOR STUDENTS
TO LEARN ABOUT THE CONTRIBUTIONS
OF THOSE WHO LOOK LIKE THEM TO
COME FROM THE SAME.
BACKGROUNDS THAT THEY DO.
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS SHARING
THAT HAS A PROFOUND AND POSITIVE
AFFECTED IMPACT ON OUR STUDENTS
IN.
AS THE FIRST AFRO LATINO EVER
REPRESENTED TO THIS OFFICE I I I
I THINK ABOUT THE EXPERIENCES OF
MY OWN ANCESTORS IN A BANK MY
CHILDREN AND ALL OF OUR CHILDREN.
DESERVE TO HEAR ABOUT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THOSE WHO COME
BEFORE THEM WHO LOOK LIKE THEM
AND WHO REFLECT THEM AND SO WE
ARE PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL.
IT IS ONE OF TWENTY BILLS IF
YOU'LL COME BACK IN THE
LEGISLATURE AGAIN --
BUT I CANNOT THINK OF A MORE
IMPORTANT BILL AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE IN THIS LEADERSHIP AND
FOR THE MEMBERS AND AUTHORS FOR
SUPPORTING IT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT AB.
THREE THREE ONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU AS CHAIR AND YOU RECEIVED IT
ALREADY SO AND IF YOU CAN.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT I
NEVER HAD THE CHANCE TO SAY.
THANK YOU SIR CAN I GET A NOTE
TO GO BACK TO CLASS PLEASE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
WITH THAT WILL GO --
TO MR GARCIA'S HE'S STILL HERE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY --
COVERED AB TWO THIRTY SIX FILE
NUMBER SEVEN FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN AS CHAIR A BEAT --
TWO THREE SIX IS A BILL THAT YOU
ARE PROBABLY VERY FAMILIAR WITH.
INTENDED TO STRENGTHEN CRITICAL
WORK OF FAMILY APARTMENT CENTERS
BY ENSURING THAT FAMILIES OF
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES.
HAVE ACCESS TO THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO HELP THEIR CHILDREN
THRIVE SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
WILL EXPAND.
HE CENTERS --
FROM EIGHTEEN TO THIRTY IN THE
DON'T HAVE CENTERS AT THIS TIME
PROVIDE A ONE TIME BASE GRANT
INCREASE IMPROVE COORDINATION
BETWEEN.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND IT'S APARTMENT
CENTERS --
WITH ME ARE TWO WITNESSES THAT
WILL PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE
DETAILS IN THE GENERAL TICKET
DIRECTOR OF FAMILY.
A SOUP AND YUBA COUNTY AS WELL
AS ELIZABETH ANGLICAN
[inaudible]
YOUR WITNESSES.
MY NAME IS CINDY CHANDLER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR FAMILY
SOUP.
WERE FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTER
SERVING YUBA SUTTER AND COLUSA
COUNTIES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY EMPOWERMENT
DISABILITY COUNCIL MADE UP OF
FOURTEEN EXISTING FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTERS.
THE PROMISE OF SB.
FIVE ELEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
WAS TO PROVIDE FOR THIRTY TWO
FEC REGIONS TO DATE THERE ARE
ONLY.
FOURTEEN THE FAMILY EMPOWERMENT
CENTERS PROVIDE CRITICAL
INFORMATION PARENT TO PARENT
SUPPORT.
SO THAT PARENTS CAN BE THE BEST
IF ADVOCATES FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES MAKE
UP BETWEEN TEN AND 12% OF THE
STUDENT BODY --
AT FTC'S HELP PARENTS ENSURE
THAT HIGH EXPECTATIONS ARE MET
WITH SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN
SUBSTANTIAL GAINS FOR THEIR
CHILD.
IF HE SEES WORK WITH FAMILIES OF
KINSHIP CARE FOSTER FAMILIES
GRANDPARENTS MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
ETHNICITIES RURAL URBAN HOMELESS
ALL ARE WELCOME AND ALL OF THE
FAMILIES NEED OUR HELP.
SUPPORT ALL DISABILITIES AND ALL
CONCERNS IF YOU SEE SIR STUDENTS
AGES. THREE TO TWENTY TWO OUR
SERVICES ARE WELL RESPECTED BY
OUR VALUED PARTNERS WE WORK HARD
TO HELP RESOLVE CONFLICT BEFORE
IT -- REACH
REACH ISN'T ESCALATES --
TO DUE PROCESS.
IF THE PARENT HAS A CONCERN
ABOUT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR
CHILD FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTERS
OF THE PERFECT PLACE TO START
THE JOURNEY TOGETHER.
HEAVY SEAS ARE REALLY REALLY
GOOD AT WHAT WE DO.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION EVALUATION OF FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTERS.
PROVIDES THE DATA TO SHOW OUR
EFFECTIVENESS.
THE STATE WIDE TASK FORCE IN
TWENTY COMMENDED FULL FUNDING
FOR THE FCC'S BECAUSE THE MOST
ACCURATE PREDICTOR OF A
STUDENT'S ACHIEVEMENT IN SCHOOL.
ITS PARENT INVOLVEMENT. ONE OF
OUR PARENTS SAID IT BEST SHE
SAID WE LOST HOPE.
BEFORE WE MET FAMILY SOUP THE
FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTER GAVE
US HOPE.
THEN I HAVE HOPE WHAT.
AND CONVICTION THAT THE PROMISE
OF SB FIVE ELEVEN DEFEND THE
THIRTY TWO FEC STATEWIDE IS
FULFILLED WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB.
TWO THIRTY SIX THE FAMILIES IN
THE EIGHTEEN REGION'S WITHOUT IF
HE SEES WAITED OVER A GENERATION.
GOOD JOB [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH ANGLE CAN AND I AM THE
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT OF
SUTTER COUNTY SPECIAL EDUCATION
LOCAL PLAN AREA.
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
A BI TO THIRTY SIX AS A SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST DISTRICT DIRECTOR
AND MORE RECENTLY LEADING A
COUNTY WIDE CELL BUT A FIFTEEN
DISTRICTS I'VE BEEN FORTUNATE TO
WORK ALONGSIDE A FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTER.
THIS PARTNERSHIP HAS BEEN A
CRITICAL COMPONENT AND SERVING
FAMILIES AT THE SCHOOL SITE
DISTRICT AND COUNTY LEVEL OUR
COMMUNITY IS A BETTER INFORMED
MORE INCLUSIVE COMMUNITY BECAUSE
OF THEIR PRESENCE MESSAGE.
AND MEANINGFUL WORK.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE FEC
IN SELF BUT IS TRULY A TWO WAY
STREET AS PARENTS ARE OFTEN
REFERRED TO OUR COMMUNITY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE UNLESS
FORMALLY. TO OFFER KNOWLEDGE AND
THAT LOCAL PERSPECTIVE NEEDED TO
UNDERSTAND TO NAVIGATE THE
COMPLEXITIES OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
THE I. D. E. A. REQUIRES THAT
FAMILIES BE INFORMED IN ORDER TO
FULLY PARTICIPATE IN THE
EDUCATIONAL PLANNING PROCESS.
THE FEC ACTS AS A LIAISON AND A
HELPFUL FACILITATOR WHEN
QUESTIONS OR NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND
BECOME IMPORTANT BARRIERS.
THE EMOTIONAL IMPACT OF LEARNING
ACCEPTING AND ACCEPTING UNDER
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF A CHILD
WITH DISABILITIES OFTEN
OVERWHELMING.
IT CAN BE FILLED WITH FEELINGS
OF GRIEF AND SOMETIMES LOSS OF
POWER ON THE PART OF THE PARENT.
THESE REALITIES OBVIOUSLY EXTEND
ALL DAY AND IT IS THE FEC THAT
PROVIDES A BRIDGE FROM SCHOOL TO
HOME OFFERING TIME TO PAY
PATHWAYS FOR COMMUNITY INCLUSION.
AND RESOURCE SHARING.
THE FISCAL AND GEOGRAPHIC
SUPPORTS OF THIS BILL WILL
ENHANCE AND EXTEND COLLABORATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION BALANCING AN
IMPORTANT COMMUNICATION PATH TO
GUIDE SERVICES.
AND FINALLY IT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF OUR STUDENTS TO
RESOLVE CONFLICTS AND DISPUTES
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
REDUCTION IN LEGAL COSTS DUE
PROCESS FILINGS AND COMPLAINTS
TO CD E. R. OUT COMES AT A OF AN
EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION MODEL WHEN MYSELF A
CREATED IT'S EIGHTY OUR TEAM AND
NATURAL PARTNER EXISTED.
DUE TO THE TRUST DEVELOPED AND
THE WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITHIN
OUR FEC. TWO THIRTY SIX HAS BEEN
ENDORSED BY MY PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATION THE STATE'S SALPA
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH PROVIDES A
COLLECTIVE VOICE FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS GARCIA AND
O'DONNELL FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
TONY THIS LONG LEGAL ADVOCATE
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
LARA GONZALEZ YUBA COUNTY SOFA
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ROB MORROW CEO OF PALS SUPPORTED
LIVING SERVICES WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ERICA HOW OFTEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JEFF BARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT.
ALICE KESSLER ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUL BUT MINISTRY HERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
MICHELLE UNDERWOOD ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION FOR ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND SUPPORT.
AND TO GARAGE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
A LEADER FISHER CHAIR OF THE
COMMUNITY ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION IN SF UST I'M
HERE BECAUSE OF MY FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTER.
STRONG SUPPORT.
KATIE BABCOCK ON IN A
REPRESENTING FIVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FROM THE NORTH REGION
CELL PUT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ADAM STEIN SNOW COUNTY SELF
ASSUME CAN I CHARTER SUB ON
BEHALF OF SEVENTY THREE
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
VERONICA CODES TAMA COUNTY SOUTH
BY REPRESENTING FOURTEEN ELEAZAR
STRONG SUPPORT.
BARBARA BLOOM MENDOCINO COUNTY
SUPPER REPRESENTING THIRTEEN
ELEAZAR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KELLY YOUNG WERE MINE FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO REPRESENTING FIVE THE
COUNTIES THAT DO NOT HAVE FEC
ALSO A PARENT OF A CHILD WITH A
DISABILITY.
SHERRI STRASBOURG HER FORMER
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER AND
PRINCIPAL OF THIS DROUGHT
CHARTER SCHOOL INVENTOR COUNTY I
HAVE FOR MY SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AND JOSEPH IN
MERION ALSO WITH LEARN FOR LIFE
INVENTOR COUNTY AND PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TEAM HERE TO
REPRESENT STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMANDA KRASNER
MATH TEACHER WITH LEARN FOR LIFE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS ALICE SCHMIDT MY
MISS SCIENCE TEACHER WITH LEARN
FOR LIFE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
DUGGAR GOKEY HOLLER FOR LIFE A
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
OKAY WITH THAT --
WILL BRING IT BACK I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU. FOR THE BELT I'M A CO
AUTHOR OF THE BILLS IMPORTANT
IT'S REALLY ABOUT HELPING
PARENTS NAVIGATE.
ARE COMPLEX SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROCESS HELPING FAMILIES HELPING
SAVE MONEY TO SOME ANSWERS THIS
IS A MONEY IN SOME INSTANCES.
TO SO WITH THAT --
IN THESE ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SINA COM INSIDE WE HAVE A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
SIX AND THEN AND OF THE OF THE
MEMBERS YOU DO ACCEPT THE
AMOUNTS.
IS THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS THE PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA KALRA
HIGH MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER I WELL AS FOR SO IT IS OUT
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WILL GO TO MISS QUIRK
SILVA.
I AB.
ONE NINETY EIGHT SHE'S TWO BILLS
AB ONE NINETY A WITH --
SO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB ONE
NINETY EIGHT IS FILE ON NUMBER.
SIX GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
HERE TO PRESENT EVERYBODY'S
FAVORITE IDEA WHICH IS THE
CAREER APTITUDE TEST.
AND A I KNOW THAT THERE'S A THIS
HAS BEEN AN EXERCISE THAT SOME
PEOPLE BELIEVE IS.
NOT WORTHY AND I HAVE TO TELL
YOU THAT THE REASON THAT I
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD I'M NOT
READING MY NOTES AT AT ALL ALL
IS --
ACTUALLY WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SEEN
THAT -- E
HAVE MANY STUDENTS SPENDING
QUITE A LONG TIME AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
SOMETIMES FOUR FIVE EVEN SIX
YEARS IN PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE
MANY OF THE STUDENTS THAT DO GO
TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES JUST
AREN'T SURE WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
AND EVEN THOUGH SOME OF US HAVE
TAKEN THESE TESTS I KNOW I DID
WHAT MANY MANY YEARS AGO THEY'VE
EVOLVED.
AND SOME HAVE SAID WELL IF YOU
TAKE THE TEST WHEN YOU'RE A
FRESHMAN WHAT IS THAT GOING TO
TELL YOU ABOUT WHEN YOU'RE
SENIOR.
OF I THINK OUR INTERESTS
INVOLVED BUT THE KEY IS TO AT
LEAST START TO GIVE STUDENTS
INFORMATION OR SOME TYPE OF
DIRECTION NOT SOME OF OUR
PREMIUM PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE IN
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE LIKE THAT
GRAHAM.
STUDENTS NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THAT
BEFORE THEY EVEN REGISTER AND
WITHOUT ANY DIRECTION WE SEE NOW
MORE AND MORE WITH THE ONLINE
INFORMATION STUDENTS DON'T EVEN
GET TO A CAMPUS. TO REGISTER TO
EVEN FIND OUT ABOUT VARIOUS
PATHWAYS ABOUT IF THEY'RE EVEN
INTERESTED IN SOME TYPE OF SITE
PROGRAM THAT COULD BE AVAILABLE
AND SO WE HAVE STUDENTS KIND OF
FLOUNDERING WHEN THEY GET TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR OTHER
COLLEGES.
SO WHY DO I THINK THIS IS SUCH A
NEW IDEA IT REALLY ISN'T NEW.
AND IT IS IT SOMETHING THAT
COULD NOT BE IMPROVED BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE STUDENTS
EXPOSED --
TO IT'S TAKING A TEST I'M
WILLING TO TAKE --
THE AMENDMENTS FOR THIS BILL BUT
REALLY HOPE THAT ALONG THE WAY
WE COULD CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT.
BECAUSE HAVING SOMEBODY GO TO A
WEBSITE UP THAT'S JUST NOT
HAPPENING MOST OF US DON'T GO TO
WEBSITE ESPECIALLY HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS SO.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT TO ME AS
I'VE BEEN ASKED NUMEROUS TIMES
BY COLLEGE COUNSELORS TO THEIR
SEEN STUDENTS WHO HAVE NO
DIRECTION.
AND HAVEN'T EVEN BEEN EXPOSED TO
ANY TYPE OF OF OPPORTUNITY TO AT
LEAST PART TAKEN ONE OF THESE
ASSESSMENTS THAT DOES NOT MEAN I
WANT TO SPEND A LOT OF MONEY ON
IT DOESN'T MEAN I WANT EVEN
SPEND A LOT OF CLASS TIME ONE
PERIOD --
WOULD COULD BE TAKEN TO TO HAVE
THEM GO ONLINE AND CLASS EVEN IF
THAT SET SO I KNOW THAT'S MORE
THAN WHAT THE BILL SAYS.
BUT BUT I WILL TAKE THE
MEASUREMENTS AND A ON PRESENT.
THIS BILL AS WHAT IS STATED BUT
I'M HOPING WE COULD CONTINUE TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION.
ALL RIGHT THAT I I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
WELL LAID OUT THAT'S FOR SURE --
ANY OTHER SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
NICOLE RICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION I APOLOGIZE FOR OUR
LATE POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT
WE ARE HERE. TO OFFER OUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL COULDN'T
AGREE MORE WITH THE AUTHOR WE DO
A LOT IN OUR K. FOURTEEN
EXPERIENCE TO EXPOSE STUDENTS ON
HOW TO GET TO COLLEGE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE A
MANDATE FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FROM THIS COMMITTEE
IN FACT FOR KIDS TO HAVE
EXPOSURE TO COLLEGE AND CAREER
SO THIS IS JUST ONE ADDITIONAL
STEP TO HELP US GET TO THAT
POINT.
AND SO WE ARE TO HOPING THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION GET THIS TOOL IN
THE HANDS OF STUDENTS. TO HELP
THEM FIGURE OUT WHO THEY WANT TO
BE WHEN THEY GROW UP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORT
SENIOR OTHER SUPPORTS ANY
OPPOSITION --
I DON'T SEE ANY OPPOSITION --
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR OF THE
BILL -- YEAH
I YOU KNOW I I WOULD SAY THE
TEST --
HAVING AN INTEREST AND EVEN
EXPOSURE ALL DIFFERENT CONCEPTS.
AND I CERTAINLY WOULDN'T WANT
SOMEONE TO TAKE A TEST IN
SEVENTH GRADE TO BE TRACKED I
KNOW THAT'S NOT YOUR GOAL EITHER.
BUT I I WAS SHARING WITH --
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL
THAT MIND MY I TOOK ONE OF THOSE
TESTS AND I CAME OUT AS CLERGY.
RIGHT.
IF YOU HEARD ME IF YOU HEARD ME
READ THE PAPER THE OTHER DAY.
MONDAY I DID PRETTY GOOD SO
MAYBE WHAT ABOUT A GOOD YOU KNOW
I WORRY ABOUT THESE TESTS I
WORRY ABOUT THAT WE DON'T.
USE THE WORD TEST WE COULD JUST
SAY --
EXPOSURE OR EVALUATION AND AND
THE REASON I IT REALLY KIND OF
STICK IT ON THIS.
IS.
FIRST OF ALL I'M NOT KING
ABOUT SEVENTH GRADERS I'M TALK
REALLY LOOKING AT A HIGH SCHOOL
SENIOR SOMETIME IN THEIR SENIOR
YEAR SO I KNOW THAT'S NOT
SPECIFICALLY HERE AND WE'RE
EVOLVING INTO THAT.
BUT I REALLY THINK OF SO MANY
STUDENTS DON'T KNOW ABOUT MANY
OPPORTUNITIES SO FOR EXAMPLE WE
VISITED PARAMEDIC PARAMOUNT
STUDIOS THIS LAST.
WEEK AND YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
EVERYTHING FROM OF COURSE THE
ACTORS BUT YOU HAVE THE
CARPENTERS ON SITE YOU HAVE THE
LIGHTING ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
NOT ONLY TRADES BUT ALSO CAREERS
AND SO OFTEN --
STUDENTS KIND OF FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE TO TAKE ONE PATHWAY AND WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S SO MANY MORE
MORE OPTIONS AND SO I'VE SAID
THIS I KNOW I'VE TALKED TO
DOCTOR WEBER ABOUT THIS.
AND PART OF IT IS LET'S LET THEM
HAVE A MENU AND LET THEM START
TO UNDERSTAND LIKE WHAT DO I
NEED TO DO TO THINK ABOUT THE
FUTURE.
AND SO EVEN IF IT SAYS YOU WANT
TO BE A MORTUARY SCIENTIST.
THERE IS A MORTUARY RIGHT AWAY.
THAT WAS RIGHT.
AT BUT THERE IS ACTUALLY ONE
WHERE YOU CAN BUILD.
HE AT THE SITE.
ALL RIGHT.
I JUST ORIGINAL I VOTE
[inaudible]
OKAY -- ALL
RIGHT BUT REALLY WHAT I REALLY
THINK YOU WANT IS EXPOSURE.
AND I I I DON'T THE CONTEST IS
EXPOSURE BUT AYE AYE.
THIS CONCEPT IS EVOLVING WE CAN
INVOLVE AREA THERE.
ALL RIGHT --
WITH THAT OTHER COMMENTS FROM
ANY OF THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YEAH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
IF IT WAS UP TO THE ASSESSMENT I
TOOK I WOULD CURRENTLY BE A
PODIATRIST --
WHICH I GOT A PRICE YEAH NOT.
BUT I AM I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS MEASURE AND I THINK THE
EXPOSURE IS THE KEY PART OF IT
AND I THINK IT'S YET ANOTHER
PIECE WE KEEP CONTINUALLY
HEARING ABOUT.
GAPS PARTICULARLY IN THAT
SECONDARY EDUCATION EXPERIENCE
THAT SPEAK TO KIND OF ADULT TING.
ONE OH ONE THE NEEDS FOR US TO
EVENTUALLY GET TO A LIFE SKILLS
COURSE THAT IT THAT INCLUDES
CAREER EXPLORATION FINANCIAL
LITERACY AND HOW TO FUNCTION AS
AN ADULT ONCE YOU GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL SO I APPRECIATE THIS.
AS A PIECE OF GETTING TO THAT
MOVEMENT EVENTUALLY.
THANK YOU WHEN I AND I THINK
THIS CONVERSATION PORTS WELL
WITH MY AND YOUR EFFORT AND
OTHERS IN THIS ROOM.
EFFORTS --
TO INSURE THERE'S ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR C. T. YEAH AND I
THINK NOW WE'RE HEADING INTO
WHAT C. T. EVEN IS.
IS IT'S IS IT KIND OF SEPARATE
FROM STEM CELL THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WERE GOING TO HAVE
THIS YEAR. FOR SURE SO --
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
THIRTY WEBER I WANT TO THANK US.
I REMEMBER FOR BEING SO
PERSISTENT WITH HER CONCERT --
AND I I THINK I I KNOW THERE'S
VALUE IN --
IN.
IN EXPOSING AND AND WHAT TO
CREATE MEANS IN THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS --
AND I'M HOPING THAT YOU WORK ON
THIS BEFORE IT GETS TO THE FLOOR
BECAUSE I THINK WHEN YOU SEE
APTITUDE TEST.
THAT IMMEDIATELY TURNS PEOPLE
OFF BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW IT'S
BEEN SO MUCH WORK DONE ON HOW
APTITUDE TEST Và REALLY NOT
VERY EFFECTIVE.
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO TELL
PEOPLE WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE THINK OF AND
I THINK IT WOULD PASS SOMETHING
THIS IS.
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE TO TAKE AN
APTITUDE TEST THAT IS WHAT WILL
TRANSLATE DOWN TO THE OTHER
PEOPLE IF IT PASSES IN GETS
FUNDED.
THEY'LL BE AN APTITUDE TEST
VERSUS TALKING ABOUT CAREER
CHOICES CAREER OPTIONS LIFE SKI
ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT AND THE
EXPOSURE OF YOUNG PEOPLE TO
CAREERS --
THAT MANY OF THEM ONLY GET YOU
KNOW YOU GET YOUR TEACHER YOUR
DOCTOR YOUR LAWYER OR MAYBE AN
ENGINEER BUT EVEN BEYOND THAT
WHAT ELSE IS INVOLVED IN THE
TEACHING PROFESSION IS MORE THAN
BEING IN.
FRONT OF THE CLASSROOM THEY
DON'T KNOW WITH SO I THINK GO.
CAREER EXPLORATION IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT --
AND SO I HOPE BEFORE THIS GETS
TO THE FLOOR THAT THE TURN
APTITUDE TESTS IS SOMEONE OF THE
DEFINED IN ANOTHER WAY BECAUSE
IF IT PASSES AS AN APTITUDE TEST
IT WILL BE AN APTITUDE TESTS.
AND AND THAT WILL NOT GO WELL
FOR STUDENTS.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT THAT WAS
THE CORRECT WORD I WAS LOOKING
FOR EXPLORATION.
AND I WILL BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOUR TEAM TO TO
AMANDA SO THAT IT WILL BE WHAT
WERE DISCUSSING.
ALL RIGHT --
WITH THAT AND NO FURTHER
COMMENTS FOR THE COMMITTEE --
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS OCEAN THIS
WITH A SECOND BY.
DOCTOR WEBER I BELIEVE --
PLEASE CALL US.
DID YOU CLOSE WAS AT A CLOSE YES.
THINK YOU'RE UP.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL THANK O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY SMITH SMITH I
WEBER.
WEBER I THE BILL HAS FOR VOTE SO
IT IS OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE TO I DON'T SEE MISTER
BERMAN OTHERS.
MR GERMAN ON MY PAPER --
ONE YOU HAVE ANOTHER ONE I'M
SORRY YOU HAVE A YES WE ARE AB
THREE FIVE FOUR FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN PHONE.
AND IT'S JUST AS PASSIONATE --
AND THIS IS WHY YOU DON'T SEE ME
PRESENT TOO OFTEN AND AND THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE EVEN THOUGH
I'VE SPENT THIRTY YEARS IN
EDUCATION BECAUSE IT'S VERY HARD
FOR ME. TO A RACE WHAT I'VE SEEN
IN EDUCATION WITHOUT GETTING
OVERLY PASSIONATE AND THIS OF
COURSE IS ABOUT LUNCHES AND WE
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT SCHOOL
LUNCHES AND TITLE ONE AND SO
FORTH.
BUT THIS BILL REALLY AIMS.
TO AB --
THREE FIVE FOUR AND WE WILL TAKE
A THE EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS BUT I KNOW FIRST HAND
THAT STUDENTS THAT COME TO
SCHOOL NOT ONLY HAVING GOOD
NUTRITION BUT ALSO GETTING IT
DURING THE SCHOOL DAY.
MAKES FOR A STUDENTS SUCCESS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT DEPEND THE
CHILDREN GO TO DEPENDS ON THE
TYPE OF LUNCH THEY GET SO THE
EXAMPLE --
FOR MY PERSONAL TEACHING AS I'VE
TAUGHT IN TITLE ONE SCHOOLS
WHERE.
THE STUDENTS RECEIVE BREAKFAST
AND LUNCH AT OTHER SCHOOLS THAT
MAY HAVE TITLE ONE STUDENTS.
BUT NOT THE LARGE PERCENTAGE
MANY TIMES THEY DON'T GET THE
LUNCH OR EVEN THE BREAKFAST.
I PERSONALLY HAVE BROUGHT THAT
UP TO THE DISTRICT I WAS WORKING
AT AND THEY SAID BECAUSE THERE
WEREN'T ENOUGH STUDENTS THAN
THEY WOULD NOT.
PROVIDE --
THE LUNCH OR THE BREAKFAST OR
SOMETIMES THEY'D GET AN
ALTERNATIVE LUNCH --
A GRANOLA BAR AN APPLE OR SO
FORTH SO THIS GOES BACK TO ST I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME TYPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY REGARDING
STUDENTS BEING ABLE TO HAVE
NUTRITION OUT SCHOOL.
AND SO THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE
THE PROPER IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
STATE MAIL MANDATE BY REQUIRING
A REPORT ON THE ALTERNATIVE MAIL
PROGRAM SCHOOLS WILL PROVIDE
WHEN OPTING OUT OF THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAM.
THIS WAY WE WILL ENSURE THAT ALL
TO SERVE DINNERS DESERVING
PUPILS HAVE ACCESS TO NUTRITION
AND THERE BY A MORE EQUITABLE
EDUCATION.
WELL THE MOVE IN SECONDED.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SHARE
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT AND WE WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
EFFORTS REGARDING FOOD SECURITY
THANK YOU.
IF YOU'RE BORN REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION WE KNOW THAT
HALF OF THE DAILY COUNT CALORIES
FOR CHILDREN.
ARE FOUND IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM
IN TERMS OF THEIR OWN LUNCH AND
BREAKFAST PROGRAMS.
THIS MEASURE WILL ENSURE THAT
ANY NUDE NEEDY CHILD HAVE ACCESS
TO THE MEALS THAT THEY NEED TO
IN THE COURSE OF THE DAY
UNFORTUNATELY SOME CHILDREN
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING OTHER THAN
THAT ONE MEAL AT SCHOOLS.
AND SO ARE WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
MISTER MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CAPITAL HOW ARE IN A BEHALF OF
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THIS BILL
LAST YEAR AND EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY ONE PASSED REQUIRING
THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS NEXT YEAR.
I BEGAN TO FEED KIDS AT SCHOOL
THEY'RE NOT ALREADY DOING THAT
THIS PUTS NEW REGULATIONS IN
PLACE BEFORE THAT BILL EVEN GOES
INTO EFFECT.
SOME OF OUR SCHOOLS HAVE OPTED
OUT OF THE FEDERAL MEAL PROGRAM
DUE TO THE CUMBERSOME
REGULATIONS AND PAPERWORK --
AND THE MEAGER REIMBURSEMENT
THIS THE CUMBERSOME REGULATIONS
AND PAPERWORK ONLY YOU HAVE NO
REIMBURSEMENT SO THE SCHOOLS --
AND PARTICULARS OF OUR LARGER
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE FEEDING ALL
OF THEIR KIDS AT SCHOOL AND NOT
SEEING THE FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT
AND NOW THEY WILL.
NOT BE ABLE TO DO THAT WITHOUT
FILLING OUT PAPERWORK AT THE
STATE LEVEL WE THINK THAT
ACTUALLY DEFEATS THE PURPOSE OF
FEEDINGHUNGRY KIDS AND WE
OPPOSE THE MEASURE.
A SINGLE OTHER OPPOSITION WILL
BRING UP BEHIND THE TO THE
COMMITTEE.
ALL THIS PRESENT A CONCERNED HE
I DON'T KNOW THE WERE REALLY
ADDRESSING THIS BILL BUT I KNOW
A CHARTER SCHOOL IN LONG BEACH
THAT.
THEY KICK THEIR KIDS OUT AT
LUNCH.
RIGHT ON A PRETTY MAJOR STREET
THEY HAVE TO GO TAKE OFF FOR AN
HOUR.
AND THEY DON'T FEED THEM BUT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO FIND A PLACE.
TO STAY FOR AN HOUR AND THEN
THEY COME BACK TO SCHOOL IT'S
JUST A CONCERN I HAVE.
IS IN THE MOMENT OKAY GOOD --
BECAUSE I GUESS THAT'S A SAFETY
CONCERN TO ME WITHIN OUR TALK
ABOUT FOOD IS YOU KNOW PUSH KIDS
OUT FOR AN HOUR I DON'T THINK IS.
IS IS A GOOD THING WITHOUT ANY
COME COME IT'S REALLY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS --
THERE'S BEEN REMOVED.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
OKAY PLEASE --
YOU YOU DO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
YES AND AS FAR AS CUMBERSOME
PAPERWORK FOR FILENE'S --
ALL OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS ENGAGE
IN THIS AND THERE'S TIMES THAT
NEEDS TO BE SPENT ON IT BUT THE
OUTCOME IS.
NOT GETTING MEALS TO STUDENTS.
SO I AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER AYE.
THE BILL HAS FOR VOTE SO IT IS
OUT THANK YOU.
WITH THAT NUMBER GO TO MISTER
BERMAN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
[inaudible]
TWENTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES I'D LIKE TO THINK
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT DESCRIBING THE
ANALYSIS.
OUR SOCIETY IS WHEN IS PROFOUND
CHANGES IN THE WAYS WE LIVE AND
WORK DUE TO ADVANCES IN
COMPUTING.
THE INTEGRATION OF COMPUTER
TECHNOLOGY INTO EVERY ASPECT OF
DAILY LIFE NECESSITATES A
FOUNDATION IN COMPUTER SCIENCE
FOR A WELL ROUNDED EDUCATION. TO
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED.
LEGISLATION IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WHICH REQUIRED THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO CONVENE A
COMPUTER SCIENCE STRATEGIC
IMPLEMENTATION ADVISORY PANEL TO
DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
COMPUTER SCIENCE STRATEGIC
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION IS
MEETING TODAY TO HEAR THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE STRATEGIC
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
GIVEN THE DEVELOPMENTS ON
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION AB
TWENTY WILL CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA COMPUTER SCIENCE
COORDINATOR WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO OVERSEE THE STATE'S
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PLAN IN
AND SHORT SUCCESS.
IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
COMPUTER SCIENCE COORDINATOR
WORK TO ADVANCE THE MISSION OF
THE COMPUTER SCIENCE STRATEGIC
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN AND PROVIDE
STATE LEVEL LEADERSHIP.
AND SUPPORT FOR INITIATIVES TO
IMPLEMENT COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS WILL HELP CALIFORNIA IN
CLOSING THE EQUITY GAP IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE FIELDS AND
PROVIDE THE WORK FORCE NEEDED
FOR CALIFORNIA TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE IN THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE HEY --
IS ALEXIS HERE AGAIN --
DIRECTOR STATE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AT C¡ DOT ORG AND
KOURTNEY JENSEN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA THE
SOUTHWEST AT TECHNET.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
COULD ORG IS A NATIONAL NON
PROFIT DEDICATED TO EXPANDING
ACCESS TO COMPUTER SCIENCE IN
SCHOOLS IN INCREASING
PARTICIPATION BY WOMEN AND
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES.
WE BELIEVE EVERY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA.
SHOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN COMPUTER SCIENCE COMPUTER
SCIENCE OPENS MORE DOORS FOR
STUDENTS AND ANY OTHER
DISCIPLINE THE AVERAGE SALARY
FOR COMPUTING OCCUPATION IN
CALIFORNIA IS ONE HUNDRED AND
TWELVE THOUSAND AND THE STATE
CURRENTLY HAS SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND OPEN COMPUTING JOBS.
COMPUTING OCCUPATIONS ARE THE
FASTEST GROWING AMONG THE
HIGHEST PAYING IT AND YET ONLY
32% OF CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS
TEACH COMPUTER SCIENCE.
FROM WE DIVE DEEPER INTO THAT
32% AND ANALYZE SCHOOLS.
OFFERING THE SCHOOL COURSES BY
URBAN VERSUS RURAL FREE AND
REDUCED LUNCH AND
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES IT
BECOMES CLEAR THERE IS A CASE OF
HAVES AND HAVE NOTS.
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION BE
VOTING LATER TODAY ON THE
ADOPTION OF THE COMPUTER SCIENCE
OR TEACHER COMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
STRATEGIES WITHIN THAT PLAN ARE
FOCUSED ON CLOSING THESE GAPS IN
EXPANDING ACCESS TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE FOR ALL STUDENTS AND IN
PARTICULAR TRADITIONALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS WE
BELIEVE.
WE NEED YOUR LEADERSHIP TO
IMPLEMENT THE STRATEGIES BECAUSE
EVERY STUDENT SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN COMPUTER
SCIENCE REGARDLESS IF THEY ARE
IN A RURAL DISTRICT OR IN HIGH
POVERTY.
ONE AB TWENTY CREATES A CS
COORDINATOR TO MAN THANKS FOR
TEACHER CLAM CO DOT ORG HAS IN
THE NEED FOR SUCH A POSITION IN
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE ADOPTED A
POLICY SIMILAR TO THOSE OUTLINED
IN THE STRATEGIC PLANNING --
AND IN AB TWENTY INCLUDING THE
ADOPTION OF THE RECENT.
WE ADOPTED THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE RECENTLY ADOPTED KID FOR
COMPUTER SCIENCE STANDARDS
EXPANDING ACCESS TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE COURSES IN GRADES K..
TWELVE AND SUPPORTING EXISTING
AND FUTURE TEACHERS TO TEACH THE
S..
WHAT WE DO NOT BELIEVE EVERY
STUDENTS TO BECOME A COMPUTER
PROGRAMMER WE BELIEVE ALL
STUDENTS NEED TO UNDERSTAND
TECHNOLOGY COMPUTER SCIENCE
ALLOW STUDENTS? TO LEARN HOW TO
CREATE TECHNOLOGY NOT MERELY BE
CONSUMERS OF IT PLEASE CONSIDER
US A CO DOT ORG --
RESOURCE FOR POLICY RESEARCH
RELATED TO COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION WE'VE COMPILED
RESOURCES FOR LEGISLATORS AND
POLICY MAKERS PASSING POLICIES
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
VERY VERY QUICK READING BY THE
WAY.
TRYING TO RESPECT THE COMMISSION
AND ADDRESS.
MR KAREN MEMBER JOURNEY.
REMEMBER THE FORTY JENSEN A TECH
MATT AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF WORK
WORLD CLASS TALENT IN THIS FIELD
COMPUTER SCIENCE IS CRITICAL TO
TECH MATT AND ITS MEMBER
COMPANIES WE'VE BEEN PROUD TO
SPONSOR COMPUTER SCIENCE
LEGISLATION AND STEM LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN LEGISLATION TO CAN BE IN
THE COMPUTER.
SCIENCE OR TO TAKE
IMPLEMENTATION ADVISORY PANEL
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO A RAPIDLY
GROWING TECHNOLOGY SECTOR BUT
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE NOT
EQUIPPED TO EDUCATE STUDENTS TO
FILL THE JOBS AVAILABLE IN THE
SECTOR.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN CALIFORNIA HAD
ONLY FOUR THOUSAND AND TWENTY
NINE COMPUTER SCIENCE GRADUATES
AND ONLY 16% WERE WOMEN 6% WERE
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND 10% WERE
LATINO WE KNOW STUDENT EXPOSURE
TO COMPUTER SCIENCE AT A YOUNG
AGE IS CRITICAL TO ADDRESS THE
DIVERSITY GAP IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE FIELD.
AND PROVIDE THE WORK FORCE NEED
FOR CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION TO
REMAIN COMPETITIVE IN THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY.
STATISTICS INDICATE THAT YOUNG
WOMAN WHO TAKE DID AN ADVANCED
PLACEMENT COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSE IN HIGH SCHOOL ARE TEN
TIMES MORE LIKELY A MAJOR IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE IN COLLEGE.
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO
STATE STUDENTS ARE OVER SEVEN
TIMES MORE LIKELY.
IT IS VITAL THAT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS HAVE GEN AND WE BELIEVE
THE COMPUTER SCIENCE COORDINATOR
INCLUDED IN AB TWENTY IS KEY TO
PROVIDING EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND TO
SOME MEMORY BERMAN --
FOR FOR CHAMPING AT COMPUTER
SCIENCE LEGISLATION WE THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST I
ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
KAREN SARKISIAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF COUNTY THE
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION A PROUD CO SPONSOR
THE MEASURE.
KEVIN CAN LEAVE THE INTERNET
DISSOCIATION.
COSPONSORED IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHEN MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS NECK
BROKE OF A SEGMENT OF ADVOCATES
HERE ON BEHALF OF MICROSOFT AND
SUPPORT?
ALSO NASA CAN BE THE SUPPORT OF
OUR FRIENDS AT THE ENTERTAINMENT
SOFTWARE ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING LA GARNER WITH
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY IN SUPPORT
THANKS.
THANK YOU AT ANY OPPOSITION.
YEAH VERY BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED Và
MOVED AND SECONDED --
WITH THAT I'LL JUST CALL IT WAS
DIFFERENT THANK YOU FOR THE BILL.
AGAIN THIS IS AN INCREMENTAL
STEP BUT WE REALLY NEED TO GET
THERE.
THIS NEEDS TO BE TAUGHT STARTING
IN SECOND GRADE I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT SO I I COMMIT TO
WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU.
AND HOW WE CAN ACTUALLY MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
I KNOW WE DO MANDATES IT'S
SIGNIFICANTLY PROBLEMATIC BUT WE
GET WE HAVE TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
BECAUSE IT NEEDS TO BE TAUGHT AT
A VERY YOUNG VERY EARLY AGE AND
INFUSED THROUGHOUT THE K. TWELVE
AND BEYOND EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE SO I COMMITTEE TO
THAT BECAUSE I GET THAT THIS IS
A A BIG DEAL. FOR THE FUTURE THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY FOR SURE
ALONG WITH THAT --
ANY OTHER COMMENTS SEEN OTHER
COMMENTS --
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
JACK CONSIDERING BETTER MYSELF
RESPECT THIS DRIVER.
AND IT ENDED MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY SMITH SMITH I
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THANK YOU THE BILL HAS
FOUR VOTES IT IS OUT.
I'M SORRY THE BILL HAS FIVE
VOTES FIVE VOTES.
I DOCTOR WEBER I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE A BILL. FIVE ITEM.
SEVEN ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE AB ONE NINE SEVEN AB.
ONE NINETY SEVEN SO THIS WILL BE
OUR LAST BILLS OF THERE'S ANY
MEMBERS WAY --
THAT STILL NEED TO ADD ON WE
DOING THAT AFTER THIS BILLS
PRESENTED SO I WOULD HAD THIS
WAY.
WITHOUT A DOCTOR WHETHER YOU MAY
ASK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT TO YOU
AB ONE NINE SEVEN WHICH REQUIRES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OFFERING
KINDERGARTEN TO IMPLEMENT A FULL
DAY PROGRAM.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
AND THIS BILL AND WE ACCEPT THE
CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
AMENDMENTS.
ACCORDING TO THE EDUCATION
COMMISSION OF THE STATES FULL
DATE SCHOOL COULD KINDERGARTEN
ATTENDANCE CAN HELP CLOSE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP EARLY IN A
CHILD'S EDUCATION.
LONGER SCHOOL DAYS ENABLE
CHILDREN TO RECEIVE MORE
STRUCTURE IN FROM TEACHERS AS
WELL AS MORE TIME INTERACTING
WITH THEIR PEERS.
THIS CAN LEAD TO INCREASED OF
SCORES AND GREATER LONG LONG
TERM ACHIEVEMENT THE POSITIVE
AFFECT THE FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
ARE EVEN MORE PRONOUNCED FOR
MINORITY AND LOW IN THE COULD
INCOME STUDENTS.
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN ITS SOURCE
REPORTED OF THAT ONLY 70% OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL SERVING
KINDERGARTEN AGE CHILDREN
OFFERING FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN.
A CALIFORNIA LAGS BEHIND MANY OF
THE STATES THAT OFFER FULL
PROGRAMS FOR LARGER PORTION THE
POPULATION OF KINDERGARTNERS IF
NOT ALL OF THEM.
BECAUSE MORE AND MORE CHILDREN
PARTICIPATE IN PRESCHOOL AND
WE'RE WORKING HARDER ON ON
PRESCHOOL CARE FOR EVERYONE AND
T. K..
IT IS A CLEAR THAT NO LONGER IS
CAN TO GUARD THE FIRST
EXPERIENCE FOR MOST CHILDREN A
MANY ARE YOU SO FULL DAY PROGRAM
AND READY FOR FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN --
IT DIGITALLY UP OBVIOUSLY THE
IDEA FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN FITS
INTO OUR WORKING COMMUNITIES OF
PSYCHE CAN TERMS OF A FAMILIES
WITH TWO WORKING INDIVIDUALS AND
NOT AND HAVING TO LEAVE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE DAY TO GET
CHILDREN OUT AFTER.
ONLY A COUPLE HOURS A PRESCHOOL
OR KINDERGARTEN SCUSE ME SOUL
THIS FITS IN TO WHERE WE ARE
WITH CURRENTLY IN INCREASING ALL
OF OUR STANDARDS FOR A CHILD
CARE PRESCHOOL --
YOU KNOW THE FOCUS AT THIS --
NEW ADMINISTRATION IS ON THAT
AND OBVIOUSLY HAVING ALL DAY
KINDERGARTEN FITS INTO THAT
ADDITIONAL HOURS PROVIDED UNDER
AB ONE NINE SEVEN WOULD EXPAND
INSTRUCTION FOR ALL STUDENTS AND
GIVE TEACHERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE.
AN ACADEMICALLY RICH EXPERIENCE
FOR EVERY CHILD I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA OR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KATHY RAVEN ON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND AS A GRAND
MAMMA OF A KID GOING INTO
KINDERGARTEN NEXT YEAR YEAH ELLE
ALL DAY.
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE PREVIOUS
JOB WHEN YOU SPOKE IN SUPPORT.
FOR THE CATHOLIC SCHOOLS.
YEAH YEAH YEAH SURE THAT THEY'RE
OFFERING HOLDING THEM RIGHT
ACROSS THE THE DIOCESE OKAY.
NEW GROWING SPORT OF THAT ARE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR THE GIFTED IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO MACKENZIE CHRISTIANSEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MY FAVORITE NOW FORMER IN
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER AND SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH ASKED ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE HAVE A
SUPORT IF AMENDED POSITION
ACKNOWLEDGING ON ADDITIONAL TIME
FRAME TO IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM
SO WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
TAKING THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT
TO HELP ADDRESS PART OF THAT.
ON THE SECOND PIECE IS THE
FUNDING IT IS UNCLEAR IF IT'S
THAN TEND TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
AB NINETY SIX OR SHOULD THE BILL
BE CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATE A
BUDGET APPROPRIATION.
CITING THE LANGUAGE AS A THREE
AND IS SILENT ON THAT.
SO WITHOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
BUILD CAPACITY OR TRUCK TRAFFIC
CLASSES TO BE COMPLIANT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WOULD HAVE TO ABSORB
THE COST GRADING ADDITIONAL COST
PRESSURES THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE ANY ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN OPPOSITIONAL RING UP BEHIND
THE THE RAIL HERE I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY YOU ACCEPT THOSE FOR A
MOMENT YES WE DID YES.
THANK YOU AND JUST A QUICK
COMMENT --
AND I THINK IT'S BUILT INTO THE
BILL THAT WE WANT TO EXPEDITE
CERTAINLY OUR TITLE ONE SCHOOLS
GETTING INTO A FULL THEY CAN --
SITUATION AND IS WANTING ALSO.
WITH KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS
ADVOCATE NOT TAUGHT MIDDLE AND
K. EIGHT THEN HIGH SCHOOL.
ON THAT OFTENTIMES --
IT SHOULD BE THIS WAY --
WHEN A SCHOOL HAS --
PART DAY CAN --
HAVE TAKEN OR WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO CALL IT THAT THE TEACHER THEN
SPENDS RIGHT THE OTHER HALF OF
THE DAY AND SOME OTHER CLUSTER
VI<c.cyan> CANDOR.</c>
OR SOME OTHER YOU KNOW.
NUMBER BUT AS A READING
SPECIALIST AND MAYBE A K. --
THREE SETTING SUCH LONG ODDS ARE
THERE IS.
THOSE TEACHERS ARE JUST DOING
NOTHING --
THEY HAVE RESPOND THE OTHER HALF
OF THE DAY RIGHT AND THEY'RE
ALSO PREPARING FOR KINDERGARTEN
CLASS WHICH IS.
TYPICALLY PRETTY AND YOU KNOW
PRETTY YOU KNOW TAKES A LOT OF
WORK BECAUSE YOU GOT A LOT OF
MINIMALISTIC CENTER THEY HAVE TO
CUT THINGS OUT FOR THE KIDS.
THEY'RE TYPICALLY NOT DOING OF
THAT AGE FOR MINE AS OUR
TEACHING HALF DAY NOW GETTING IN
THE CAR AND GOING HOME.
THE ACTUALLY SHOULD BE SERVING A
A PURPOSE THE REST OF THE DAY ON
THE SCHOOL SIDE SO THAT WILL
HAVE AN IMPACT TO I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
SO WITH THAT --
MISS SMITH.
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR AUTHORING
THIS MEASURE IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT WE PILOTED THIS IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT I'M FROM IN.
A BY AND LARGE PARTICULARLY IN
OUR TITLE ONE SCHOOLS FOUND THAT
THE ACHIEVEMENT --
THAT WAS GAINED BY ADDING JUST
THOSE FEW PRECIOUS HOURS OF
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME FOR
KINDERGARTNERS WAS WELL WORTH
THE EFFORT MY ONLY CONCERN AND I
I KNOW YOU'RE ENGAGE WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS IS ENSURING
THAT WE'VE GOT --
ADEQUATE APPROPRIATE FACILITIES
ACROSS ALL DISTRICTS THAT
PLANNED TO IMPLEMENT THIS AS
WELL AS AN TO THE CHAIRS POINT I
JUST NOW ABOUT ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT STAFF THAT MAY BE NEEDED
YOU KNOW KINDERGARTEN IS A VERY
INTENSE HANDS ON ROBUST
CURRICULUM AND SO IF ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT STAFF ARE NEEDED IN
TERMS.
OF CURRICULUM SUPPORT THAT WE
MIGHT LOOK AT THAT IN THE FUTURE
AS WELL BUT I THINK YOU FOR THIS
MEASURE AND I'M IN SUPPORT.
GREAT --
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS --
YOU MAKE CLOSE YEAH I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY THANK YOU FOR
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE MADE
AND I WE'RE CONSCIOUS OF ALL OF
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
IN TERMS OF OF WHAT MAY HAPPEN
IN SCHOOLS UNFORTUNATELY WE DO
HAVE SOME ROLE MODELS WHICH ARE
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE.
IMPLEMENTED A FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN AND SOME OF THE THE
HAD TO BE OAK FEW YEARS BACK TO
DO THE STUDY AS TO WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN WOULD SCHOOLS IN TERMS OF
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN.
SO WE HAVE A STUDY THAT TALKS
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION SO IT'S
NOT LIKE SOMETHING THAT WOULD
JUST DOING FOR THE FIRST TIME SO
THIS WOULD UP.
BASICALLY BE THE SECOND STEP
AFTER THE STUDY WOULD WE HAVE TO
BASICALLY TALK ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION OF KINDERGARTEN --
AT A FULL DAY ALL DAY KIND OF
EXPERIENCE SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
BUT I BOTH.
ONE NINE SEVEN THANK YOU THE THE
BILL THAT WE NEED A MOTION.
BEEN MOVED BY MISTER SECOND WAS
YOUR CALLER THE MOTION IS --
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY.
SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER HI WEBER I IT IS
FOR WHEN THE BILL IS OUT WE'RE
NOW GOING.
TO FIRST WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
LIFT THE CALL SO.
THIS THREE BILLS SO --
WE'RE NOT GOING LIVE TO CALL ON
THREE BILLS --
WHEN READY YOU MAKE CALL THE
ROLL ON THOSE THREE BILLS?
FILE ITEM THREE AB.
TWENTY EIGHT THE VOTE COUNT IS
TWO TO ZERO THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I THE VOTE THE HOUSE FIVE
VOTES IT IS ON THAT IS AB.
TWENTY I'M SORRY.
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB.
TWO NINETY SEVEN SIR. TO
SEVENTEEN TWO NINETY SEVEN THE
VOTE COUNT IS THREE TO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY. FIVE THE BUS
FIVE VOTED IS OUT OF THIS FIGHT
AB.
TWO NINETY SEVEN IT IS OUT.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB.
THREE NINETY SIX THE ACCOUNT IS
TWO TWO ZERO THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE KILEY.
KILEY IN NOT VOTING KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTED
IS OUT THAT'S AB.
THREE NINETY SIX NOW WE'RE GONNA
HAVE.
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF UNDER FOR
ADD ONS MEMBERS IF YOU WISH TO
ADD ON TO ANY BILL PLEASE STAY
SEATED --
WITH YOUR MICROPHONES ON SO THE
COMMITTEE SECRETARY CAN CALL THE
ROLL FOR MORE ADD ONS
[inaudible]
YES.
SEC SO I WILL DURING THE MEETING
THAT WE WILL WE WILL STAY HERE
FOR ADD ONS.
CALDERON EACH ITEM [inaudible]
CHOOSE [inaudible]
YEAH -- MM
FROM THE WE THEM ALONG CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AB IS.
A FIFTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS A C.
R. [inaudible]
EIGHT KALRA [inaudible]
I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I FILE ITEM ONE AB
[inaudible]
EIGHT KILEY.
THE OTHER.
NOT VOTING KILEY [inaudible]
OF MCCARTY.
FILE ITEM TO AB [inaudible]
TWENTY MCCARTY.
FILE ITEM FIVE AB.
ONE NINETY SEVEN MCCARTY.
FILE ITEM SIX AB ONE NINETY
EIGHT KILEY.
KILEY I'VE MCCARTY.
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB TWO THIRTY
SIX KILEY.
KILEY I'VE MCCARTY.
FILE ITEM.
EIGHT AB TO NINETY SEVEN MCCARTY.
FILE ITEM NINE AB THREE THIRTY
ONE KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA I FILE ITEM TEN AB THREE
FIFTY FOUR KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY NO [inaudible]
PARTY.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB THREE NINETY
SIX MCCARTY.
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I
OKAY